[Musique]
Tikenja Facoli. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Je m'appelle Dumbia Mousa à l'état
civil. Mon nom d'artiste c'est Chicken
Ja Facoli. Je suis né en 1968
euh en Côte d'Ivoire dans le Nord
précisément et ça fait presque 30 ans
que je fais de la musique regée.
Voilà et j'aime qu'on appelle l'africain
d'origine ivoirienne. Voilà parce que je
me bat pour l'Afrique parce que je sais
que c'est l'Afrique qui va gagner et que
les pays pourront pas gagner
individuellement mais que c'est ensemble
que les 54 pays vont gagner. Donc
j'essaie de me projeter dans le futur
pour voilà pour être l'africain au lieu
d'être simplement ivoirien.
Et puis bon voilà, on fait l'interview
et puis à la fin on va quand même
chanter deux titres puisque je suis
artiste. Voilà. Ouais, on va se faire
plaisir.
On a décidé de vous interviewer
aujourd'hui pour avoir votre expérience,
votre ressenti, votre perception de ce
qui se passe sur le continent.
Ma première question, c'est est-ce que
l'Afrique va mal et est-ce que l'Afrique
ira mieux ou est-ce que l'Afrique ira de
mal en pis ?
Ben moi, je dirais simplement que
l'Afrique se trouve dans un processus
normal. C'est un continent qui sort de
400 ans d'esclavage, plusieurs années de
colonisation et voilà, je pourrais dire
même que la colonisation continue la
nuit. Euh nous avons eu l'indépendance
en 1960,
la plupart des pays africains
francophones en tout cas et nous avons
applaudi. Nous avons danser et nous
pensions que nous étions libres mais en
fait nous n'étions pas libres parce que
le lendemain des indépendances il y a un
réseau FOCAR qui a été mis en place qui
a fait et et qui a fait pendant des
années et qui a défait euh les chefs
d'état en Afrique. Voilà, la première
fois qu'on a entendu parler de du mot
que moi j'ai entendu le mot mercenaire,
c'est pas dans un dictionnaire, c'est
Bob Denard et qui était pourtant
français. Et donc voilà, je pense que
l'Afrique est dans un processus normal.
Vous savez, quand euh vous êtes colonisé
nuitamment pendant 60 ans, euh c'est un
peu compliqué de de vous euh euh de vous
développer euh avec vos propres moyens.
Euh donc voilà, on a fait croire
d'ailleurs pendant presque 60 ans que on
ne pouvait pas vivre euh finalement
indépendant sans les autres. Donc voilà,
moi je dis que l'Afrique est dans un
processus normal.
Le réveil commence que maintenant
et je pense que si on continue, voilà,
parce que les réseaux sociaux sont venus
renforcer
notre combat, quand j'ai dis notre
combat, moi ça fait 30 ans que je dis
aux africains réveillez-vous, personne
ne viendra changer l'Afrique à notre
place. Et donc, il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde a sa télé
et on peut voir tout ce qui se passe
dans le monde entier. Et donc je pense
que ça a un peu accéléré la
compréhension des gens et que
aujourd'hui euh le réveil ne fait que
commencer. Voilà. Maintenant, donc pour
répondre à votre question, je dirais que
l'Afrique est dans un processus normal.
Voilà, c'est dans un processus normal de
démocratisation, de développement et
surtout euh de de réveil.
Je check juste avec mon réalisateur qui
qui a l'air de s'emmêler les pinceaux.
Dis-moi, est-ce qu'on est toujours en
direct ou est-ce que tu veux qu'on
relance le direct ?
Totalement en direct.
On est totalement en direct. Est-ce que
tu peux me mettre la miniature
correctement s'il te plaît ?
Revenons. Revenons à la question
géopolitique pure et dure.
À l'heure actuelle, on entend mot
génocide.
On entend que le Sénégal, il y a des
déstabilisations. On entend que le
Congo, il y a des déstabilisations.
Est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles
concernant ça ? Oui, j'ai des nouvelles
par rapport au Sénégal, hein. Je pense
que la date des élections était fixée et
la campagne devait commencer et
malheureusement, on vient d'apprendre
que le président du Sénégal a décidé de
reporter les élections avec euh
finalement l'accord des députés du parti
présidentiel. Et donc je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui va mettre le feu aux
poudre. Je pense que le Sénégal est un
pays euh où il y avait voilà, il y avait
le balai citoyens. Donc le balai citoyen
euh pardon, il y en a marre parce que le
balai citoyen c'est le Burkina Faso.
Donc le Sénégal avec le balai citoyen
avec beaucoup de mouvements de la
société civile, je pense c'est un pays
qui est qui est réveillé et que la
pilule va passer en tout cas
difficilement parce que voilà voilà
c'est un pays dans lequel il y a des
jeunes dynamiques, il y a des jeunes
réveillés qui sont qui sont prêts pour
le changement et donc je pense que la
pilule du report des élections va passer
difficilement maintenant au Congo. Oui.
Les nouvelles que j'ai c'est que Goma
avait été a été encerclé. J'ai pas trop
de détails, mais je pense que voilà,
très souvent c'est une région du Congo
qui est menacée par des rébellions euh
des rébellions et j'espère que une
solution sera trouvée pour que euh ces
populations là soient moins emmerdées
parce qu'à chaque fois c'est des
villages qui qui sont détruits, c'est
des morts, c'est des des voilà des des
populations qui sont qui prennent le
chemin de l'exil.
Euh je pense c'est une région qui a
beaucoup souffert en tout cas de cette
des histoires entre le Rwanda et le
Congo et j'espère qu'une solution sera
trouvée rapidement pour que la
population retrouve leur tranquillité.
On parle souvent d'ingérence russe,
d'ingérence chinoise, d'ingérence
française en ce moment et d'ingérence
américaine.
Hm hm.
Quel est le l'ingérence la plus
délétaire à court moyen et long terme ?
Ben, je pense que il y a toutes les
ingérences depuis très longtemps. Sauf
que euh le problème c'est que
pendant longtemps,
l'Afrique n'a eu l'Afrique étant une
boutique qui a des matières primières à
vendre euh qui a des produits à proposer
au monde. Alors, l'Afrique n'a eu qu'un
seul client, c'est l'Occident. Voilà.
Donc quand vous avez une boutique que
vous avez un seul client et que surtout
c'est le client le client se donne la
possibilité de fixer le prix de des
marchandises qui se trouvent dans vos
boutiques, alors vous êtes obligé d'être
finalement dépendant de ces clients-là
pendant des décennies. Et donc
aujourd'hui euh l'arrivée des Chinois et
des Russes et cetera, moi ça me dérange
pas. Moi, j'ai dit on a d'autres clients
maintenant, ça peut nous permettre euh
de monter les enchès, de dire "Bon voilà
euh tel truc, les autres l'acheté à tel
prix, maintenant nous on veut tel prix
et puis bon, on choisira le celui qui va
faire la meilleure offre." Voilà, c'est
comme ça que je vois. Maintenant euh
ce qui est déplorable, c'est comment les
dirigeants gèrent cette situation,
comment nos terres sont bradées, comment
nos matières premières sont bradées, euh
comment on s'attache aux Russes ou aux
Chinois parce queon sait que c'est pas
des pays euh où la démocratie est assez
à un niveau important et donc voilà, on
peut massacrer son peuple et continuer à
travailler avec la Chine. on peut
massacrer peuple ou continuer à
travailler avec la Russie alors que les
pays occidentaux posaient quand même des
questions et je pense que c'est là qu'il
y a le problème. Mais sinon, le fait que
euh tous ces continents euh tout t tous
ces clients finalement s'intéressent à
l'Afrique, c'est une bonne chose.
Maintenant, comment nous les africains
on gère ça ? Comment nous on va gérer ça
? Je pense que c'est là la question.
On va on va rentrer plus dans le détail
de ces ingérences.
Hm. les bruits, les ce qu'on vous fait
remonter sur le terrain, est-ce que
c'est coordonné ? Est-ce qu'il y a
encore des agents de l'ombre ? Est-ce
qu'il y a encore des corruptions ? Quel
type de corruption ? Comment ça ça
procède ? Ben, il y a des choses qui se
passent, c'est que par exemple quand la
Chine donne des marchés ou des des des
des voilà des
des crédits,
alors c'est ce sont des généralement des
entreprises chinois
qui vont euh euh
qui vont faire le travail et surtout ils
vont venir avec des employés chinois.
Euh donc le le le ça fait que on donne
l'argent et après ça répare. Mais je
crois que c'était un peu le même système
que les pays occidentaux. Je pense que
c'est tout ça qu'il faut revoir et
personne ne peut euh
redresser cette situation ou bien
corriger cette situation si ce n'est que
les africains. Et c'est pourquoi nous
travaillons pour le réveil de l'Afrique.
Nous travaillons pour rendre les
dirigeants indépendants parce qu'il faut
que les dirigeants soient libres de
décider quand un dirigeant s'attend euh
au soutien de la France ou le soutien de
la Russie ou le soutien de la Chine pour
pouvoir rester au pouvoir. Alors, il
peut pas défendre correctement l'intérêt
de son peuple. Et donc, je pense que
c'est tout ça qui doit être revu. Mais
moi, j'ai l'habitude de dire qu'il y a
que le peuple qui pourra en tout cas
redresser tout ça. Euh dès qu'on pas
quelque chose, il faut se mettre
ensemble pour protester ou dénoncer
comme cela se fait en France ou aux
États-Unis. Quand les gens quand vous
touchez l'emploi, la santé euh vous
touchez en tout cas il y a un certain
nombre de choses quand vous les touchez.
Alors le peuple oublie d'où il vient, le
peuple oublie son parti politique, le
peuple oublie sa région, je veux dire et
il se tout le monde se met ensemble pour
défendre l'intérêt général. Je pense que
c'est ça qui manque en Afrique et c'est
ça qu'il faut il faut que il faut que
des choses comme ça arrivent en Afrique.
Comment les Africains aussi peuvent se
libérer de leurs propres dirigeants qui
s'accrochent au pouvoir de famille en
famille comme les anciens rois ? Ben, je
pense que les politiques travaillent en
Afrique généralement euh ils divisent
pour m régner et donc parce que ils sont
conscients que nous sommes plusieurs
ethnies dans nos pays, ils sont ils
savent aussi qu'on qu'on est un peu
régionaliste, euh voilà régionaliste.
Euh ils savent aussi que voilà donc ils
profitent de ça et je pense que la seule
solution c'est que le peuple les peuples
se mettent ensemble qui se mettent
au-dessus des religions, des religions
et cetera et qui se mettent ensemble
pour se faire respecter par celui qui
est au pouvoir. Voilà. Euh voilà que se
mettent ensemble. Moi, je pense que
c'est la seule solution euh parce que en
réalité on fait croire que ce sont ces
dirigeants là qui ont le pouvoir mais
moi je pense que c'est le peuple qui a
le pouvoir. Je pense que le peuple
divisé est faible et le peuple uni est
fort. Et donc je pense qu'il faut que
dans nos pays, on soit ensemble pour
défendre l'intérêt général.
La liberté d'expression en Afrique, elle
varie selon les pays où il y a une une
uniformalisation de la liberté
d'expression où est-ce qu'on continue de
couper les connexions internet, on
continue de mettre les opposants
politiques en prison.
Mais je pense que dans beaucoup de pays,
on continue de mettre les opposants en
prison. Il y a des pays où on coupe
internet. Il y a des pays où on peut
plus parler. Par exemple, les trois pays
aujourd'hui, le Niger, le Burkina Faso
et le Mali. Euh voilà. C'est aujourd'hui
interdit de critiquer, de dénoncer des
choses sous les régimes qui sont en
place. Et moi, je trouve que c'est
doubleurable, même si je pense que ces
pays-là sont euh dans une résistance euh
contre euh le néocolonialisme,
euh même si je je pense que je suis sûr
aussi enfin je pense que ces pays-là
sont euh dans un truc où ils veulent en
tout cas se libérer, ils veulent J'ai
l'habitude de dire que l'indépendance
qu'on nous a donné en 1960, c'était la
photocopie et que notre génération a
décidé de réclamer la vraie vraie copie
et donc
je suis avec eux dans ce combat pour la
résistance et la récupération de la
vraie copie de l'indépendance mais je
suis contre le fait que on emprisonne
tous ceux qui veulent s'exprimer voilà
tous ceux qui veulent parler qui veulent
dire des choses contraires à la manière
de voir des gens qui sont au pouvoir
mais sont les met en prison et je pense
que ça c'est déplorable et ça c'est
déplorable parce que euh beaucoup de
combats ont été menés pour avoir cette
liberté d'expression et donc venir parce
que on veut résister, parce qu'on veut
se libérer, donc il faut qu'il y ait euh
la réflexion soit dans un seul sens. Euh
je refuse cela. Et donc ça dépend des
pays. Il y a ça dépend des pays euh en
Afrique. Voilà, il y en a il y a des il
y a des la en tout cas je pense qu'il y
a un gros combat encore à mener pour la
liberté d'expression dans la majorité
des pays africains.
Comment vous voyez le l'avenir du
continent avec le réchauffement
climatique ? Est-ce que est-ce que les
africains doivent écouter les pays
occidentaux
et ne pas utiliser leurs ressources
d'énergie fossile ?
Est-ce que le continent est prêt avec ce
réchauffement climatique à utiliser la
science et la technologie pour pouvoir
se protéger des vagues de chaleur, des
inondations à outrance, des des des
vagues de parasites qui viendraient avec
la chaleur comme les criquets, les
épidémies sur les cultures et j'en
passe. Comment vous sentez la
préparation du continent face à cette
menace ? Mais le continent n'est pas du
tout prêt. Il faut des mesures euh
concrètes.
Voilà. Euh et voilà, quand vous parler
de réchauffement climatique en Afrique,
euh en conseil, com j'en parle par
exemple, je sens que les gens ils s'en
foutent. Ils s'en foutent alors que euh
alors que ça doit être ça doit nous
inquiéter. Vous savez, en Afrique, notre
problème c'est qu'on met tous Dieu.
Voilà. Alors que Dieu, il est très
occupé. Il doit s'occuper des Chinois,
il doit s'occuper des des Russes, il
doit s'occuper des Européens, il doit
s'occuper des Américains
des Français.
Et des Français. Bon, les Français font
partie de l'Europe, donc il doit
s'occuper de tout le monde. Alors, si
nous on compte sur lui pour nous
protéger et cetera, et il faut qu'il
nous voit en action. Il faut qu'on voit
les africains euh
contrôler les histoires des déchets. Euh
il faut queon voit les Africains se
préoccuper. Il faut qu'on voit aussi les
africains prendre le courage des
jcidentaux. C'est vous qui polluez.
Euh et puis nous nous nous avons les les
conséquences de votre pollution. Alors,
il faut qu'on ait aussi le courage que
l'Afrique se mette ensemble pour dire
aux occidentaux, vous êtes développé
grâce au
euh certaines vous avec les grâce aux
usines, grâce à des choses. Et donc si
on veut équilibrer aujourd'hui, comme
nous on a besoin de développement, il
faut que vous arrêtez vos usines et que
nous on rattrape un peu le retard et
donc il faut qu'on ait le courage de
tout ça. Et ça ne peut pas se faire si
on ne forme pas un bloc pour pour faire
passer ce message là aux pays
occidentaux. Donc l'Afrique, elle n'est
pas prête. Elle n'est pas prête parce
que voilà, elle dit Dieu est grand, Dieu
va nous aider. Voilà, moi je je dirais
que l'Afrique n'est pas prête et que il
faut simplement qu'on prenne conscience
de ce qui va se passer. Parce que vous
savez les religieux parlent de la fin du
monde. Moi je vois pas Dieu en train de
prendre son marteau un jour et puis
casser tout.
Je je vois pas. Il nous aime tellement
tu vois. Il a dû travailler fort pour
nous créer pour créer cette planète.
Donc je le vois pas en train de se lever
un matin pour tout casser et puis euh
c'est la fin du monde. Mais par contre,
je pense que c'est nous-mêmes les hommes
qui allons provoquer cette fin du monde.
C'est nous-mêmes en ne respecte pas la
ne respectant pas la nature, en en
négligeant euh tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui. Tous les jours, on a des il
y a des signaux, il y a des il y a des
en tout cas il y a des trucs qui qui
nous reviennent et qui doivent nous
effrayer.
Tu as des exemples ? Ben, on a la
banquise, je crois. C'est c'est comme ça
qu'on appelle voilà qui voilà qui qui
est en train de de fondre. On a j'ai vu
quelques quelques il y a quelques jours
la sécheresse en France. Qui aurait pu
imaginer la sécheresse en France ? La
sécheresse pour les Français c'était
loin. C'était en Éthiopie, c'était dans
le Sahel. Mais aujourd'hui, on a des
régions de la France qui qui ont des
problèmes d'eau. On a quand on voit les
images, on a l'impression que c'est des
c'est le désert qui se rapproche. Et
donc je pense que euh on doit faire
attention à ça. On doit faire attention.
J'ai l'habitude de dire que la planète,
elle nous parle, voilà, elle peut pas
s'exprimer comme nous. Donc elle donne
des coups, boum, c'est sûr. Boum, trop
de pluie, boum, trop de vent et cetera.
et elle espère qu'on va détexter le
message et qu'on va se dire "Mamed,
avant il y a il y a 100 ans euh euh nos
parents ils ont pas connu ça. Donc il y
a 200 ans c'était comme ça. Mais
pourquoi c'est comme ça aujourd'hui ?"
Je pense qu'il faut se poser des
questions pour éviter que cette fin du
monde là arrive parce que ça peut
arriver. Vous savez, la terre n'est pas
grande. Par contre, il y a beaucoup
d'eau. Euh, on a vu, on a été tous
traumatisés par le tsunami. Euh voilà.
Et donc je pense que on est et puis on
est tout le temps surpris. Chaque année
en Californie, il y a des feuxs de
brousse, des feux de forêts qui brûent
des hectares.
Des feux de brousse,
des feux de voilà la brousse parce que
nous en Afrique on dit feu de brousse et
donc les feux de forêt, les feux qui
attaquent les forêts, on sait pas voilà
malgré toute notre technologie, malgré
toute notre connaissance, mais chaque
année, il y a le mêmes feu. Mais ça
vient d'où ?
Si c'était des gens qui mettaient le feu
avec tous nos caméras aujourd'hui, avec
les drones, on allait se dire bon, c'est
la période de CS ou c'est la période où
il y a eu euh le feu l'année dernière.
Donc il faut surveiller l'endroit et je
pense qu'on aurait on aurait pu attraper
ces pyomanes là. Mais euh au Portugal,
c'est la même chose. Chaque 2 ans, on a
des Donc la planète, elle nous parle à
nous de l'écouter et à nous de détecter
son message. À nous de de de de voilà à
nous de de de changer de comportement.
Et donc voilà, je pense que euh
l'Afrique n'est pas prête. Euh
finalement personne n'est prêt parce que
il y a eu le je combien les réunions au
Maroc en France les gens ils ont parlé
parlé parlé puis il y a rien. Et donc je
pense qu'il est temps qu'on pense aux
nouvelle génération parce qu'on aime nos
enfants. Tout le monde sait hein tous
les matins on se lève on les dépose à
l'école on a envie de les avoir grandir.
Maintenant, est-ce que nous on pense à
demain
dans quel environnement ils vont vivre,
sur quelle planète ils vont vivre,
est-ce que l'air va être pollué ? Est-ce
que est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que ces
questions là on se pose ? Je pense qu'on
doit ajouter ces questions-là à notre
amour pour nos enfants et les futures
générations.
Je voudrais je voudrais que tu me parles
de du terrorisme en Afrique.
Qu'est-ce qui crée le terrorisme ?
Comment ils peuvent recruter ? Pourquoi
il y en a ? Si tu veux me parler de la
Zawad, si tu veux me parler de
d'Al-Qaïda, si tu veux me parler de tous
ces mouvements, comment ils font pour
recruter en Afrique ? Quel est le terro
de recrutement là-bas ? C'est la
pauvreté, le manque d'éducation, c'est
qu'on leur propose du pognon, des 44,
des motos ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
C'est la religion ? C'est quoi ? Je
pense que c'est la pauvreté. C'est la
pauvreté. Et donc euh et le fait que ces
régions aujourd'hui euh qui sont où il y
a beaucoup de terrorisme, ces régionsl
ont été oubliées pendant très longtemps
par les gouvernants euh voilà par les
les le gouvernement central dans le dans
le pays. Et donc le Mali par exemple,
moi je suis allé à Gao ou à Tambutu, je
suis pas encore arrivé à Kidal mais
voilà, j'ai vu que il y a pas eu de
développement. il y a pas eu
développement et donc si on avait créé
des usines euh si on avait créé des
usines ou des moyens pour les jeunes
d'avoir du boulot euh je ne pense pas
qu'on en est là. Mais je pense que
l'autre raison aussi c'est la corruption
parce que j'ai vécu au Mali, je sais que
euh beaucoup de gouvernants de de
comment on appelle euh Alpha Conaré à
ATT euh euh
je pense qu'ils ont donné des moyens à
des ressortissants euh du nord du Mali,
de Kidal ou de Tomboutu et cetera et qui
ont utilisé l'argent pour faire autre
chose. Parce que vous savez à Kidal,
chez les Toc par exemple, il y a
beaucoup de tribus et donc quand un chef
un cadre d' d'une tribu est choisi et
qu'on lui donne les moyens pour
développer la région pour faire des
choses, ben cet argent se trouve être
distribué entre les membres de la tribu
et l'autre tribu se plaint, prend les
armes encore. Et donc je pense que les
deux raisons, c'est euh c'est d'abord la
pauvreté et euh la corruption. Et il y a
aussi un truc, vous savez quand vous
allez à Bambako vous voyez des petits
talibés qui ont voilà qui qui demande de
l'argent aux gens. Moi personnellement
je leur donne jamais d'argent parce que
je trouve que si tout le monde refuse
s'ils n'ont pas d'argent le marabou qui
les envoie va peut-être faire un champ,
ils vont aller cultiver, ils vont faire
quelque chose pour manger. Mais si on
leur donne de l'argent que chaque soir
ils viennent faire le point parce qu'on
leur donne un quota. Par exemple au
Mali, je sais que c'est 1000 à 1
Ouais. 1000 ou 1500 francs par jour. Ils
doivent amener 1500 francs par jour.
Souvent quand ils n'ont pas ils
n'amènent pas la recette, moi j'appelle
ça une recette. S'amèneent pas, ils sont
ils sont chicotés, ils sont mal
maltraités. Et donc moi je donne pas
maintenant moi je me dis ces gens-là on
les voit jamais adolescents.
C'est-à-dire que moi j'ai l'impression
que quand ils grandissent ils sont
recrutés, ils vont l'autre côté parce
que quelqu'un qui depuis l'âge de 8 ans
euh est dans les rues en train de
demander l'argent finalement il sait pas
que c'est par le travail qu'il faut
demander l'argent, qu'il faut gagner de
l'argent. il sait pas en fait puisque
ils pensent que il faut juste demander
on te donne. Et donc ces gens-là quand
ils ont 15 16 ans, je pense
personnellement qu'ils sont recrutés par
les chefs terroristes
et qu' se retrouvent dans le nord du
Mali ou dans ou au Burkina ou au Niger
prendre les âmes et puis on leur fait
croire que ils vont aller au paradis.
Voilà qui vont aller au paradis et que
voilà que il faut qu'il refuse peut-être
le paradis d'ici. Voilà travailler le
paradis maintenant.
Voilà voilà il faut moi je dis qu'il
faut il faut vraiment avoir le paradis
d'ici d'abord parce que les chefs
religieux ils ont le paradis d'ici tu
vois. Ils vivent dans des grandes
maisons, ils ont des grosses bagnoles,
leurs enfants vont dans les écoles euh
les plus importants. Et donc euh voilà,
ça c'est un premier paradis euh qu'on
doit donner à tout le monde. L'eau,
l'électricité, l'école, la santé, ça
doit être la la nourriture, ça doit être
euh le premier paradis. Et donc euh et
donc moi je pense que le problème du
terrorisme c'est euh la pauvreté et le
terrorisme. Il faut que les gouvernants
euh après avoir combattu euh gagner la
guerre, j'espère hein j'espère que ça va
pas durer éternellement après avoir
gagné la guerre contre le terrorisme, il
faut mettre des budgets importants pour
pouvoir développer ces régions. Et je
pense que c'est la seule solution pour
que les jeunes au lieu d'aller prendre
les âmes suivent les terroristes. Je
pense que c'est la seule raison qui peut
faire qu'ils vont rester et qu'ils vont
travailler et puis vont nourrir leur
famille.
Comment vous expliquez que la France se
soit fait
beauté les fesses d'Afrique ?
Mais la France est partie parce que
euh
ça pouvait pas durer éternellement,
c'est-à-dire on peut pas être maître de
l'Afrique, on peut pas être maître
éternellement. La France est partie
parce que euh
elle est partie ou on l'a fait partir ?
Elle
elle on l'a fait partir parce que
simplement
c'est les Africains ou c'est les Russes
qui l'ont fait partir ? Non, je pense
c'est les africains. Je pense que vous
savez, vous savez quand vous venez euh
en 2013 au Mali et que vous dites que
vous venez combattre le terrorisme et
que euh
de 2013 à 2021 euh il y a pas vraiment
de résultat et que vous venez installer
euh une armée des Nations Unies ou des
ONG euh qui qui veulent pas combattre
les terroristes les terroristes et qui
se disent que leur mission C'est euh le
maintien de la paix, maintien de la paix
dans une région qui est occupée par les
terroristes. Et donc, je pense que la
France a été euh virée par manque de
résultats. si vous employez quelqu'un ou
bien quelqu'un vient vous aider
euh et que quelques années après, vous
voyez que euh la personne n'arrive pas à
atteindre l'objectif euh que vous lui
avez fixé, bon, vous lui dites bye bye
et je pense que c'est ça. Puis la France
a fait croire au départ qu'elle est
venue seulement pour défendre le Mali.
Vous savez, Gao Gao se trouve à 3h
d'avion de l'Élysée. Donc un état
islamiste installé dans le nord du Mali.
Alors un missile lancé là-bas, ça peut
atterrir à l'Élysée. Je dis l'Élysée euh
pour ne pas dire Paris ou voilà. Et donc
c'est vrai qu'elle était là pour aider
le Mali à ne pas être envahi par les
terroristes, mais elle était là aussi
pour défendre son intérêt. Et donc
voilà.
C'est quoi son intérêt ? Bon, je pense
son intérêt éviter qu'il y ait un état
terroriste à 3h de Paris. Elle était là
aussi pour défendre. Il paraît qu'il y a
des richesses, pas de preuves, mais
apparemment c'est une région assez riche
en uranium et peut-être en je peux pas
dire non puisque beaucoup de Français
ont l'électricité grâce à à l'uranium du
Niger.
Et donc la partie où exploité où on
exploite l'uranium du Niger n'est pas
loin de la frontière du Mali. Donc ça
veut dire qu'il peut avoir une
continuité des ressources quelque part
et donc je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
raisons. Euh voilà mais si elle était là
que pour nous défendre, elle n'allait
pas se fâcher du tout. Si vous venez
défendre quelqu'un et que la personne
vous dit "Non, ça va, je peux me
débrouiller, vous vous fâchez pas." Vous
voyez un peu ? Et puis le choix du Mali
et du Burkina et du Niger. Voilà. Vous
savez quand
il y a un incendie chez vous,
vous ne choisissez pas entre l'eau de
mer, l'eau de lagune ou le rivière.
Voilà, vous prenez tout ce qui est haut
pour éteindre le feu. Et donc
aujourd'hui, ces pays-là ont le droit
d'aller d'aller prendre l'eau de rivière
ou l'eau de ou l'eau de mer pour venir
éteindre le feu. Et donc, on ne doit pas
en vouloir à ces pays-là aujourd'hui
d'être allé vers la Russie ou la Chine.
Voilà. Et donc euh euh voilà un peu ce
que je peux dire sur l'histoire du
terrorisme dans le nord du Mali.
Quand on voit le
les bannières antifrançaises dans les
manifestations,
c'est quelqu'un qui pousse à faire ça ou
ça vient de la population ? Bon euh vous
savez, moi je
je pense que voilà, c'est des gens qui
personnellement en fait qui
qui sont devenus un peu euh
voilà, il y a des exagérations dans tout
hein. Euh moi par exemple, je suis
contre le fait que quand il y a des
manifestations,
je suis contre le fait qu'on voie des
drapeaux euh russes.
Voilà, je suis contre ça.
Pourquoi ? C'est oui parce que vous
pouvez pas quitter Pierre et aller vous
jeter dans la main de Paul.
Voilà, la Russie, elle se battra
toujours, elle viendra peut-être donner
un coup de main pour redorer son image
ou pour montrer qu'elle est influente,
mais elle ne fera rien pour rien.
Elle elle fera tout ce qu'elle donnera,
elle essaiera de récupérer quelque part
parce que en Russie il y a des chômeurs,
parce qu'en Russie il y a des gens qui
dorment dans les rues, parce que en
Russie, il y a des gens qui n'ont pas
peut-être l'eau ou l'électricité et donc
que la Russie hein prenne comme ça cet
argent pour venir nous aider, moi j'y
crois pas. Et donc je pense que ce que
nous devons chercher, c'est être
totalement indépendant.
Ne si on veut pas les drapeaux français,
il faut pas vouloir les drapeaux russes
ou les drapeaux chinois. Il faut notre
drapeau. Il faut le Mali, le drapeau du
Mali, le drapeau du Burkina, le drapeau
du Niger ou le drapeau en tout cas des
pays qui ont décidé de prendre la vraie
copie de l'indépendance. Donc il faut
pas compter sur quelqu'un parce que
personne ne fera rien pour rien. Et donc
voilà un peu mon avis.
Kaddafi,
il a été euh élu roi de l'Afrique. H
pourquoi ?
Ben Kaddafi euh parce qu'il voulait être
roi déjà. Voilà, il était roi de la
Libye, il voulait être loi de l'Afrique
parce qu'il voulait défendre l'Afrique.
Mais je pense que effectivement, il
était dans l'intention, il avait
l'intention de défendre l'Afrique parce
que c'était pas quelqu'un que qu'on
pouvait intimider.
Euh là, on parle de vraie indépendance.
Kaddafi, il était totalement
indépendant. Il était indépendant
économiquement, il était indépendant
politiquement. Donc son intention
c'était d'élargir ça euh sur toute
l'Afrique.
Et malheureusement au moment où Kaddafi
est attaqué par Sarkozi, l'Afrique est
moins réveillée.
L'Afrique était moins réveillée.
Aujourd'hui, Kaddafi aurait vécu euh je
pense que l'Occident allait avoir du mal
à le bombarder. Comment ça s'est passé ?
Kaddafi, on pouvait lui reprocher des
choses. Vous savez, quand vous faites 42
ans au pouvoir, vous pensez vous vous
considérez comme un représentant de Dieu
sur terre, vous faites ce que vous
voulez. Donc Karafi faisait ce qu'il
voulait.
Euh mais euh il était profondément
panafricain. Je pense qu'il voulait
défendre l'Afrique. Il avait les moyens
et il avait compris comment Babylone
fonctionne, comment l'Occident
fonctionne. Et donc il voulait
simplement
défendre les Africains. Mais
malheureusement et il était un peu en
avance.
Parce que quand on tue Kaddafi euh même
beaucoup d'Africains applaudissent
parce qu'on savait pas. Voilà, c'est 20
c'est quelques années après qu'on se
rende compte que il était il avait comme
projet de défendre l'Afrique par exemple
de de financer un satellite pour que le
téléphone le téléphone puisse nous les
frais de téléphone pour ê puissent être
moins cher pour que l'Afrique soit
indépendant. Je pense qu'il avait des
projets comme ça qui étaient
intéressants.
Je sais qu'il a manqué un peu de
modestie parce que quand vous avez un
projet comme ça, il faudra impliquer
tout le monde. Il faudra pas forcément
vouloir se mettre au-dessus de tout le
monde. Et ben, je pense qu'il a fait
quelques erreurs comme ça. Mais sinon,
il était profondément panafricain. Et si
on l'avait défendu, s'il avait vécu
encore plus et que
il était arrivé dans cette période où
les Africains sont mieux réveillés grâce
aux réseaux sociaux, je pense que il
n'allait pas mourir comme il a été tué
euh comme un chien. Et nous, on trouve
déplorable que ceux qui l'ont tué sont
en liberté.
Se promènent aujourd'hui pour faire des
conférences dans des écoles, dans des
universités.
Euh voilà que ceux qui l'ont tué
euh par vengeance personnelle finalement
parce que on lui a proposé des armes
qu'il n'a pas voulu acheter parce que il
a pas voulu mettre son argent
parce qu'il voulait peut-être
monétiser son pétrole avec autre chose
que du dollar.
Oui. Non, on l'a tué parce que il
voulait être indépendant. il voulait
totalement indépendant et qui voulait
libérer l'Afrique. Mais je pense que
s'il avait vécu aujourd'hui, on l'aurait
défendu.
On l'aurait défendu. Vous imaginez euh
au moment où Kaddafi est encore là,
des chefs d'état africains se
mobilisent, décident de monter tous dans
un avion pour aller essayer de
convaincre Kaddafi. Et ces chefs d'état
sont menacés par le président d'un pays
qui leur dit "Si votre avion vole, je
l'abat. Vous voyez un peu donc c'est la
preuve palpable que nous n'étions pas
indépendants.
Qui a menacé ?
Ben je pense que le chef de ceux qui ont
attaqué Kadfi, c'est Nicolas Skozi et
tout le monde le sait. Mais nous avons
Il y a des preuves de ça, c'est des
sources. Oui, je pense que avec tout ce
qui est dit aujourd'hui, enfin tout ce
qui tout ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui, tous
les témoignages qu'il y a voilà par
rapport au financement de la campagne de
SarkoZi, par rapport à au fait que ils
étaient, il y a il y a eu des preuves de
tout ça
bien sûr, je pense que mais on connaît,
on sait en fait en France à chaque fois
qu'un dirigeant français fait des
conneries en Afrique, alors on le met
dans un procès éternel, c'est-à-dire le
procès dure jusqu'à sa mort, tu Tu vois
les Chirak, les Focals, les tout le
monde était en procès jusqu'à leur mort.
Ils sont morts parce que voilà, ils sont
morts en procès en fait. Et donc mais
euh
quelle quelle conséquence ça a eu
l'effondrement de Kaddafi,
l'effondrement de la Libye ?
Mais l'effondrement de la Libye, c'est
le c'est c'est c'est tout ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui au Mali, au Burkina, le
terrorisme parce que le Kaddafi était
était un pont. Kaddafi était un barrage.
Kaddafi avait voilà et donc je pense que
parce qu'il était dur, parce qu'il avait
des prisons sanguinaires, parce que il
avait
Mais en tout cas ce qu'on sait que c'est
après la mort de Kaddafi que le Mali a
été envahi. Ce qu'on sait que c'est
après la mort de Kaddafi que euh le Mali
se trouvait dans cette situation, que le
Burkina s'est retrouvé dans cette
situation. Et donc je pense que voilà,
les auteurs sont là en liberté et nous
en tant qu'africain ça nous fait mal. Et
donc j'espère qu'un pays africain aura
un jour le courage d'arrêter Nicolas
Skozi de passage dans nos pays,
j'espère. Mais je pense pas qu'il va
aller dans les pays où on peut
l'arrêter. Voilà. Mais euh ça fait un
gros gâchi. C'est des pays le pays que
le Burkina quand avant quand on allait
au Burkina, quand on allait au Mali euh
voilà, c'était des pays qui étaient
sollicités sur le plan tourisme. Même
des avions atterrissaient dans le nord
du Mali, à Bayangara, à Sévaré, je
crois. Et les avions allaient
directement là avec les touristes qui
allaient visiter le pays d'OG et cetera.
Et donc tout ce manque à gagner
aujourd'hui euh euh c'est grave. Et donc
moi je pense que on espère que ce procès
de Nicolas Skozi euh va aboutir et que
il y a pas que lui, il y a Tony Blair,
il y a Tony Blair, il y a
comment on appelle ? Il y a il y a un
qui se promène dans le pays là et enfin
le premier qui a son homme échappe mais
euh son nom échappe et un qui est allé à
Bengazi son nom échappe qui a fait un
direct pour lui.
Un philosophe
ouais un philosophe mais son nom
m'échappe mais je pense que tout le
monde le connaît. Bon ces gens comme ça
il faut qu'ils soient en prison.
Pourquoi ? Mais parce qu'ils ont fait
Mais selon moi
parce que les conséquences de leurs
actes ont foutu un bordel pas possible.
C'est les
au départ il pensait peut-être pas faire
de bordel.
Oui mais vous savez
l'avocaté du diable. Mais vous savez euh
le voleur il pense pas qu'il fait quand
après avant avant de voler, je pense pas
qu' il pense forcément euh je vous savez
peut-être que je je m'exprime mal mais
euh
la conscience humaine a besoin
d'exemplarité. Voilà, quand euh les gens
font des conneries, il faut que ça soit
corrigé pour que d'autres évitent de
faire des conneries. Et si c'est pas
fait, ça va continuer. Il y a un qui va
se lever un jour, qui va aller euh euh
prendre de l'argent quelque part et qui
va mener euh euh des situations comme ça
s'est passé en Libye qui voilà.
Aujourd'hui, il y a un bordel pas
possible dans le Sahel parce que il y a
quelques gars qui se sont levés le matin
qui ont décidé soit de se venger, soit
de le bordel pour se faire
plaisir finalement ou bien pour leur ego
ou pour l'argent pour de l'argent. Et
donc je reviens pour dire que la
conscience humaine a besoin
d'exemplarité. Il faut corriger les
erreurs pour éviter qu'il y ait
d'autant.
En Afrique, c'est qui le plus exemplaire
de tous des en terme de gouvernement ?
Quel est le leader africain selon vous
qui est le plus exemplaire et qui a une
chance de porter une unification de
l'Afrique ? Or, je pense pas qu'il a un
dirigeant qui fait l'unanimité
aujourd'hui. En tout cas, en Afrique
francophone, c'est un peu difficile.
C'est c'est compliqué aujourd'hui.
Voilà. Personne ne fait l'unanimité. Je
sais que dans certains domaines
euh il y en a qui ont avancé, il y en a
qui ont fait avancer leur pays. Je
prends l'exemple de la Côte d'Ivoire euh
qui était un pays à zéro, qui
aujourd'hui est l'un des plus grands
pays de euh l'Afrique de l'Ouest. C'est
un pays débout aujourd'hui et donc je
pense que le président ivoirien a fait
un bon travail mais en même temps
euh les injustices, les inégalités, il y
a des grosses tâches dans sa
gouvernance. Donc je ne pense pas que
lui lui je pense que lui fait pas
l'unanimité. On a vu hier, il y a
quelques temps euh Macky Sall qui a
décidé de partir et qui s'est donné le
droit de reporter les élections et une
décision qui va mettre le feu à son
pays. Euh et Paul Kagamé euh l'Oranda
était un pays à zéro. Aujourd'hui, c'est
un pays debout,
très propre euh où il y a beaucoup de
choses qui évoluent mais en même temps,
il s'éterise au pouvoir et en même
temps, il crée des problèmes aux
congolais. Euh voilà et donc je pense
que euh il y en a qui ont fait avancer
les choses mais qui ont des tâches et
qui ne leur permettent pas de faire
l'unanimité aujourd'hui. Et donc en
Afrique francophone en tout cas, je ne
vois pas un dirigeant euh que tous les
africains peuvent apprécier et tous les
africains peuvent accepter de suivre. Je
vois pas mais peut-être que ça viendra.
Je pense que aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'il s'appelle tickenja
Facoli.
Non, pas forcément. Pas pas du tout.
Moi, je ferai pas de politique du tout.
Voilà, je ne ferai pas ce que Bob Malin
n'a pas fait. Voilà, moi je suis un
réglement. Ma mission sur terre, c'est
de veiller les consciences, c'est de
galvaniser mon peuple pour le pour qu'il
sache que personne ne viendra changer sa
situation à sa place. Donc euh voilà, je
pense que peut-être qu'on un jour on
aura un dirigeant. Aujourd'hui, on a les
trois dirigeants de les deux les trois
dirigeants de l'AS qui sont quand même
appréciés. Assimi Goita, euh le
capitaine Traoré et celui du Niger qui
ont aujourd'hui euh l'acclamation de
d'une partie des africains. Je dis une
partie parce qu'il y a d'autres qui ne
sont pas d'accord avec nous, nous qui le
qui qui souhaitons qu'ils aillent
jusqu'au bout.
Et ceux-là, on doit les respecter. On
doit respecter. Moi, en tant qu'artiste
en tout cas, je sais que j'ai des fans
partout et je dois respecter tout le
monde. Et mais nous attendons que
ces trois présidents atteignent
l'objectif de libération de l'Afrique et
qu'il gagne le combat contre le
terrorisme et qu'il prouve euh que
ensemble qu'il nous donne un résultat
positif et comme on en est pas là donc
voilà euh je dis qu'aujourd'hui personne
ne fait l'unanimité sur le continent
africain. Si je vous dis CDAO, ça vous
fait penser à quoi ?
Ben, communauté des États de l'Afrique
de l'Ouest qui est comp
et la l'Ouest pour pour ceux qui ne
savent pas, c'est
Ouais. C'est comm la communauté euh des
États de la OK. CDAO. Mais la pour ceux
qui savent
la ES
l'alliance des
des pays du Sahël, des États du Sahel.
Voilà. Et donc la CDAO,
elle a perdu sa crédibilité
complètement. La CDAO a perdu, c'est la
communauté des États de l'Afrique de
l'Ouest. C'est une communauté qui qui a
été créée pour l'entraide, qui a été
créé pour le rapprochement, qui a été
créé pour la libre circulation dans nos
pays, qui a été créé pour renforcer pour
que notre économie ait une force. Euh et
mais c'est devenu aujourd'hui un
instrument
qui entretient la dictature, qui un
instrument qui ne dit pas la vérité, un
instrument que qui est rejeté
aujourd'hui par euh les jeunes et donc
c'est un instrument qui n'a plus de
sens. Moi, je pense qu'elle gagnerait à
se renouveller, à même changer de nom et
à se renouveller pour regagner une
crédibilité. Et donc euh euh c'est une
communauté aujourd'hui en fait qui est
complètement rejetée par la nouvelle
génération parce qu'elle ne dit pas la
vérité. Euh voilà, je veux dire, elle
prend position selon euh euh
selon le visage de celui qui est menacé
ou bien celui qui a fait des conneries.
Et donc je pense que c'est une
organisation qui est complètement
discréditée aujourd'hui et qui ne fait
plus le poids. Et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs les trois pays du Sahel ont
décidé de de la quitter euh parce que
ils ont trouvé que euh ces trois pays
trouvent que il y a voilà c'est une
organisation qui ne joue plus le rôle le
rôle qu'elle a joué dans les années 70
après les indépendances.
Donc voilà, pour moi c'est elle
gagnerait à se renouveller et à
reconquérir sa crédibilité ou elle
gagnerait à disparaître carrément
puisque quand on n pas écouter en tant
qu'organisation, il vaut mieux
disparaître.
Si l'Afrique arrive à voir son
indépendance en tant que continent à
faire, on va dire, une Union européenne
africaine ou du moins un continent qui
fait bloc contre toutes les ingérences,
que ce soit extérieur ou intérieur ou
piloté de l'intérieur pour faire éclater
la
l'unité. Hm
hm.
Si elle arrive à voir ça, comment elle
va faire pour résister entre le bloc
américain, le bloc Chine-Russie et les
restes de l'Europe ?
Comment elle va faire ?
Ben ce qu'elle va faire c'est que elle
va gagner tous les combats. Elle va
gagner tous les combats parce que vous
savez aux Nations- Unies, on n'est pas
écouté.
Pourquoi ?
Ben parce qu'on n'existe pas vraiment.
On existe en morceau. L'Union européenne
c'est grand. C'est 26 ou 27 pays, je
crois. 26. avec le départ de
l'Angleterre, je crois et
les États-Unis, c'est 50 ou 52 États. La
Chine, elle est grande par sa puissance
économique et par sa population, par sa
par sa marine,
voilà, par sa marine, par en tout cas,
elle est c'est un grand pays. La Russie
elle est grande
et puis la Côte d'Ivoire elle est toute
petite. Le Mali est tout petit, le Bou
mais comparativement aux États-Unis,
quand vous avez 52 États d'un côté et
que vous avez la grande Chine, vous avez
la grande Russie, la Côte d'Ivoire c'est
tout petit, le Mali c'est tout petit.
Donc il faut mettre tous les petits
ensemble pour être un grand et en en ce
moment, on nous écoutera. Vous savez,
l'Afrique a la majorité des matières
primières dont les pays occidentaux ont
besoin pour continuer leur
développement. Vous savez euh quand vous
parlez de café, voilà, il y a une grande
majorité des Français qui se lèvent le
matin, s'ils ont pas le café, ils pètent
les plombs. Vous avez euh le chocolat
qui vient du cacao. Alors, si vous dites
au petits français ou au petits
américains qu'il y a plus de chocolat,
il y a beaucoup qui vont péter les
plombs. Voilà. Et la Côte d'Ivoire est
le premier producteur de cacao dans le
monde avec 40 ou 45 %. Le Ghana est 2e
producteur avec 20 %. Nous sommes déjà à
65 %. Quand vous ajoutez les 15 % du
Nigéria, nous sommes à 80 %. Quand vous
ajoutez les petites productions de la
Guinée forestière, les petites
productions du Burkina, aujourd'hui
commence à à faire du café, du cacao
et du bon.
Voilà. et du bon et donc voilà
une petite partie de l'Afrique qui
nourrit le monde entier en chocolat en
cacao je veux dire vous voyez et donc
voilà un continent si vous parlez d'or
de l'or on n'est pas on n'est pas à la
queue.
Vous parlez d'uranium on n'est pas à la
queue. On est devant cobalt
de cobalt. Vous savez, il y a une
matière au Congo Kinshasa
euh qui se trouve dans tous les
téléphones portables. Connaissez-vous
aujourd'hui
euh une personne sur cette planète qui
n'a pas de téléphones portables ? Et je
pense que c'est en tout cas c'est très
rare. Et donc ce continent là ne doit
pas être derrière. Ce continent doit
être devant. Nous devons être devant
mais nous sommes derrière parce que nous
sommes divisés. Nous sommes derrière
parce que nous sommes divisés en tout
petit pays. Vous voyez un peu. Donc moi
je pense que le jour que les 54 pays
africains seront ensemble, je sais que
c'est pas pour maintenant, mais ça peut
être dans 100 ans, je pense que nous
allons gagner tous les combats. Je dis
dans 100 ans parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
problèmes à régler d'abord dans nos
pays, dans nos régions.
Ce sera pas trop tard.
Non, ça sera pas. Vous savez, le monde
est créé depuis très longtemps. Le monde
existe depuis longtemps. Et donc s'il y
a pas cette fin du monde annoncée par
les religieux, ça peut voilà, ça sera
pas trop longtemps. Peut-être moi
j'exagère, je dis 100 ans, mais ça peut
être dans 50 ans parce que le monde est
tellement ouvert aujourd'hui avec les
réseaux sociaux, ça peut aller très
vite. Donc moi, je pense que l'Afrique
gagnera tous les combats euh quand nous
serons unis. Je l'ai chanté il y a il y
a très longtemps et je continue à le
dire.
Ça va faire mal. Ça va faire mal parce
que on nous on va nous écouter. On nous
écoute pas aujourd'hui parce que on est
tout petit dans nos pays. Le jour qu'on
fera bloc alors euh on sera obligé de
nous écouter. Je peux te poser une
question ? Hm
hm.
Tu dis si on peut se tutoyer
bien sûr.
Tu dis quand nous serons unis, ça va
faire mal. Hm
hm.
Est-ce que tu penses que les pays
occidentaux
qui savent pertinemment les décennies,
les moitié de siècle
d'ingérence, de déstabilisation de
gouvernement, de petits arrangements
entre amis ? Est-ce que tu penses que
notre classe dirigeante occidentale
a peur de cette vengeance quand ça va
faire mal de rappelez-vous bien
quand vous vous êtes bien foutu de nous,
quand vous avez blagué, hm
hm.
Maintenant nous sommes forts et vous
allez payer. Hm
hm. Est-ce que l'Afrique
doit montrer qu'elle n'est pas
revancharde ou est-ce qu'elle peut
montrer qu'elle n'est pas revancharde
pour accélérer ce processus ? Est-ce que
tu penses pas que les pays occidentaux
anticipent la vengeance des pays
africains et c'est pour ça qu'ils les
maintiennent dans un d'un état végétatif
?
Euh je pense pas que les Africains aient
l'intention de se venger. Je pense que
les Africains ont juste
envie euh de se libérer.
Tu comprends ma question ?
Ouais. Euh est-ce que je pense que euh
les euh oui, les pays occidentaux mais
depuis la fin de la colonisation, ils
ont compris que si nous sommes unis, on
va faire mal. Je pense que vous savez ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans les Sahël,
c'est pas nouveau hein. Dans les années
60, nous avons les Modibo Keita, les
Kamuken Kruma les Seoutouré
qui avaient décidé de faire cette union
déjà mais ils ont été presque tous
assassinés ou éjectés du pouvoir parce
que
Thomas Sankara aussi, tu Thomas Sankara
aussi c'est le dernier.
Mais euh ils ont vite compris que
l'Afrique unie euh fera trembler le
monde comme le général Deol avait dit
que quand le Chine va la Chine va se
réveiller, le monde va trembler. Je
pense que pendant très longtemps, ils
ont bien compris, ils ont compris que
quand l'Afrique va s'unir, quand les
africains seront ensemble que le monde
va trembler. Et donc tout a été fait
pendant très longtemps pour éviter que
cette union là soit concrète.
Sauf que aujourd'hui avec les réseaux
sociaux, on commence à comprendre
l'importance de cette union. Et donc euh
je pense que évidemment ceux qui veulent
qu'on reste à l'arrière du train, ceux
qui veulent qu'on reste donc ils vont
travailler à ce que cette division
continue.
est à nous maintenant de d'aller dans le
sens contraire, de nous rapprocher de
faire des choses ensemble
pour qu'on puisse nous respecter, pour
qu'on puisse nous écouter, pour qu'on
puisse surtout nous considérer. Parce
que vous savez,
pendant longtemps, la France était la
voix des pays francophones africains aux
Nations- Unies. Pendant très longtemps,
c'est la France qui qui qui prenait des
décisions et cetera. Et donc il faut que
euh au conseil de sécurité nous soyons
respectés. Il faut que nous ayons la
parole sinon le droit de vote quand il y
a des grandes décisions dans le monde.
Et je pense que cela ne se fera que
quand nous allons représenter ce bloc de
54 pays. Et même si aujourd'hui il y a
10 pays africains qui se mettent
ensemble euh pour expérimenter, je pense
que ça va pès vraiment dans la balance.
Parle-moi de Thomas Sankara, comment il
est perçu en Afrique ? Est-ce qu'il y a
encore le souvenir ?
Ben, c'est le Tier africain, c'est le
Tevivara africain, c'est le libérateur.
C'est celui qui a donné sa vie pour
nous. Parce que
vous savez euh
et c'est comme Secoutouré qui a dit non
au général de Gaul en 1958.
Excusez-moi du thème mais il fallait
avoir les couilles quand même.
Vous avez c'était très pollu.
Ouais, c'est très pollu. Ouais,
excusez-moi mais il fallait vraiment
être voilà pour dire non au général de
Gaul en 1958
euh où on sortait juste de la
colonisation où on était même encore
colonisé. Et je pense que Thomas Sankara
euh entre tous ces présidents
France-africains donc au Figi en Côte
d'Ivoire, Moussa Traoré au Mali euh euh
et cetera, Yansingbé et Yadema au Togo,
euh tous ces bébés de la France, être
parmi eux et dire ce que ce qui ce
qu'ils pensaient. Moi, j'ai trouvé que
c'était trop fort. Je pense que
il est venu pour créer euh euh il a vécu
pour créer le choc pour que nous
puissions nous réveiller et je pense que
c'est un repère pour nous. Je pense que
nous nous existons parce que lui il l'a
été. Nous nous essayons aujourd'hui. Le
courage qu'on a aujourd'hui de dire les
choses, je pense que c'est Sankara qui
nous a inspiré. Et vous savez la vérité
chez nous, on dit euh le mensonge prend
l'ascenseur et la vérité prend
l'escalier, mais la vérité arrive
toujours.
Thomas Sankara quand il est mort, on a
regardé dans son compte euh enfin dans
son compte, il y avait que 150000 francs
CFA.
Foudni était l'un des chefs d'état les
plus riches de la planète.
Mais quand vous allez dans les capitales
africaines aujourd'hui, mais il n'y a
pas d'effigieux de fa sur les sur les
baka ou les sautrama ou les minibus qui
circulent dans nos dans nos capitales ou
les taxis.
Alors, vous avez la photo de Thomas
Sankara, de Patrice Lemumba, de Quam
Kruma. Euh et donc c'est ça. Et donc
pour euh répondre à votre question,
voilà, je dirais que Thomas Sankara euh
c'est notre guide, celui qui sinon nous
on pensait c'était la pensée unique, tu
vois. Voilà. Moi par exemple, j'ai
applaudi au faux de Boy, tu vois. On
disait, on disait c'est le sage de
l'Afrique mais en fait dans le mot sage
c'était c'était l'œil la voix de la
France. C'était ça au fait de Boigier.
Parce qu'on se rappelle quand petit, il
y a tous les chefs d'état de la région
qui venaient voir le sage de l'Afrique.
Mais en fait, pour parler à la France,
il fallait aller parler au sages de
l'Afrique qui devait appeler la nuit
pour faire le contrer-endu. Et donc
voilà un peu ça c'est et donc
voilà Thomas Sankara
nous a réveillé et je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui est éternel dans notre
pensée, qui est éternel
dans notre manière de faire les choses
et je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui est
définitivement un héros pour nous
encein
euh pas on peut pas parler de de parce
que c'était quand même un président, il
a fait de la politique euh il a il a
fait arrêter des gens, il y en a qui
sont morts sur son régime, donc on peut
pas le considérer comme saint, mais on
peut le considérer comme un libérateur.
On peut le considérer comme quelqu'un
qui a
émancipé,
voilà, qui a émancipé, qui a contribué à
l'émancipation
de l'Afrique.
Là, à l'heure actuelle, en France, en
Europe, en Italie,
on voit énormément de gens arrivés par
bateau
h
qui sont stationnés ensuite dans des
camps euh qui n'ont pas de toilettes,
qui n'ont pas de d'essence,
le minimum rien. Ils sont entassés. Il y
en a énormément qui meurent dans la
Méditerranée. H
parle-moi de ça.
Comment tu le vois ? Pourquoi ? Comment
?
Bah c'est dommage. Je trouve que c'est
dommage que
ces jeunes gens viennent se
suicider finalement puisque la Méridanie
est devenue l'un des plus grands
cimétières de la jeunesse africaine.
Voilà. D'ailleurs, à chaque fois que euh
j'ai un titre que je chante sur scène
qui s'appelle "Où est-ce que tu vas
Alors, je rends hommage à SOS
Méditerranée qui fait beaucoup pour
sauver des vies. J'ai passé une journée
dans leur bateau qui était euh voilà
dans une ville. Enfin, on n pas Ouais.
On n' pas bougé mais j'ai visité le
bateau, j'ai vu un peu les conditions
dans lesquelles il travaillent et
tout ce qu'ils investissent pour aller
sauver nos frères.
Je trouve que c'est dommage. C'est
dommage que que ces jeuneslà payent
autant d'argent pour aller se se
suicider finalement. Vous savez, il y en
a qui payent 3000 € il y en a qui payent
5000 €
qui donnent ça au passeur pour aller se
trouver dans cette condition. Dans ces
conditions. Voilà.
Et avant les marchés aux esclaves en
Libye.
Ouais. Il faut il faut parler de ça.
Oui. Oui, il y a eu le marché des
esclaves. Non, je vais je trouve
vraiment que c'est dommage. J'espère que
ça va s'arr un jour. Je sais que il y a
des raisons. Je sais qu'il y a des
raisons que il y a le manque d'emploi.
C'est que des gens trouvent ça comme
solution pour euh améliorer leurs
conditions de vie. Je sais que il y en a
qui sont mal informés parce que ceux qui
sont déjà à Paris ou à Washington euh
qui qui prennent des photos sur les
Saint-Élysées devant des belles voitures
qui ne les appartiennent pas et qui
s'habille en GTI, excusez-moi, je je là
je fais de la pub, je suis désolé, mais
qui s'habueille dans des habits très
chers.
Euh je pense tout ça ça a de l'influence
sur ceux qui sont restés là-bas et je
trouve que c'est dommage et moi je dis
que les africains ont le droit de partir
parce que les occidentaux viennent en
Afrique travailler, rester s'ils
veulent.
Mais moi je dis que si on veut que les
choses changent en Afrique, il faut
rester en Afrique pour affronter les
difficultés. Il faut affronter la
situation politique. Il faut euh se
battre ensemble pour que pour exiger le
changement à nos dirigeant euh que de
venir euh
se suicider euh dans la Méditerranée euh
ou venir faire l'esclave finalement en
Europe. Et j'ai l'habitude de leur dire
que au temps de l'esclavage,
si nos parents avaient tous embarqué
dans les grands bateaux volontairement
pour aller, l'esclavage n'allait jamais
être aboli. Et donc moi je suis contre
le départ de ces jeunes, bien que je
comprends un peu leur situation mais je
dis que la solution ce n'est pas de fuir
le continent mais la solution c'est de
rester sur le continent se mettre
ensemble pour exiger à nos dirigeants
euh ce qu'il faut pour qu'on ait euh des
meilleures conditions de de de vie.
Parce que ces dirigeants, pourquoi ils
vont pas dans les hôpitaux en Afrique
pour se soigner ? Pourquoi ils viennent
en France ? Parce que même savent qu'ils
ont mis un système pourri de santé en
place. Euh voilà, vous savez, ça fait 25
ans,
25 ans ou 30 ans, 25 ans que je viens en
France.
Euh,
je suis allé au cimetière trois fois,
c'est-à-dire les gens que je connais, il
y a trois qui sont morts. Et puis c'est
pas voilà, c'est c'est voilà, c'est
Bachou. que je connaissais. Je suis allé
à son voilà, je suis allé j'ai un grand
fan qui s'appelle Jeans euh je suis allé
à son funérail et puis je crois que je
suis allé une troisème fois. Mais
pendant ces 25 ans, je sais pas combien
de fois je suis allé au ce métier en
Afrique, vous savez, tu vois, on dirait
que la mort rôe là-bas. Mais parce que
les gens sont mal soignés, parce que les
gens les les structures de santé euh il
y a les structures de santé quand vous
rentrez, c'est tellement pas propre,
c'est tellement mal entretenu que au
lieu de de guérir, vous tombez encore
malade. Le nombre d'enfants qui meur,
j'ai l'habitude de dire que
plein d'enfants devaient sauver
l'Afrique mais ils sont morts à
l'accouchement. Voilà parce que on n'
pas pu les protéger et cetera.
Et donc euh
moi je pense que la solution ce n'est
pas de partir enfin c'est c'est de
rester sur place pour que nous puissions
ensemble euh pousser nos dirigeants à
créer des situations sur place. Par
exemple, comment il faut stopper ces
dirigeants qui viennent se soigner en
Europe ? Quand on apprend qu'ils sont
malades, ça va se soigner, il faut aller
bloquer l'aéroport.
Mais vous lui dit mais voilà monsieur
vous avez construit un hôpital là vous
avez pass c'est passé à la télé que
c'est l'un des meilleurs du pays de la
région qui est le meilleur médecin mais
pourquoi vous voulez pas le voir
pourquoi vous prenez l'avion pour aller
auprès du contribuable aller vous
soigner en France alors que vous avez
dit que les hôpitaux que vous avez
construit sont les meilleurs. Et donc
voilà, tout ça pour dire que c'est le
peuple qui a le pouvoir quand il est uni
et que le peuple peut trouver des
solutions à tout ça. Le changement peut
passer par
euh l'union pour s'attaquer, enfin
rester en tout cas se mettre ensemble
pour exiger les meilleures conditions de
vie à nos dirigeants. Comment tu
analyses
les
pays européens qui du moins la
population de certains pays européens
qui s'insurgent contre l'immigration non
contrôlée ? Comment tu tu analyses leur
perception ? Est-ce que tu penses que
c'est normal ? Est-ce que tu penses que
c'est pas normal ? Est-ce que tu
anticipes plus de mouvements à cause du
réchauffement climatique, de plus de
déstabilisation en Afrique, de famine dû
au réchauffement climatique ? ou parce
que l'Europe produit plus assez de blé
pour nourrir l'Afrique ou que l'Ukraine
peut plus exporter son blé à cause de la
guerre ou que les Russes freineent un
peu pour donner du blé. Comment tu
perçois la population européenne qui dit
"On veut plus d'immigration ? Pour toi,
c'est des racistes ? Pour toi, c'est des
gens qui protègent leur pays. Pour toi,
comment tu les perçois ?
Mais je pense qu'il y a un peu de tout.
Il y a du racisme, il y a des gens qui
voilà qui
ne veulent pas que euh on vienne
finalement remplir leur pays et et donc
euh
voilà, moi je pense que
euh je ne dirais pas, je veux pas dire
c'est des gens qui ont tort, mais je dis
que les faits sont là. Les pays dont les
populations viennent aujourd'hui ont été
appauvrés par le système occidental.
Pendant des décennies, on a pillé les
richesses de ces pays. On a appauvri ces
pays pour les maintenir dans cette
situation en soutenant les dictateurs.
Parce que quand la France s'entend avec
un président et qu'elle sait que ce
président n'investit pas
pour son pays et qu'elle continue quand
même à entretenir des bonnes relations,
il faut qu'elle s'attende un jour au
retour du bâton. C'est ce qui est
arrivé. Si dès les indépendances
on avait euh
exigé la transparence
parce que après l'indépendance, le pays
colonisataire avait encore du pouvoir
qui a été utilisé autrement. Mais si ce
pouvoir-là avait été utilisé pour exiger
aux dirigeants
de faire des choses dans leur pays pour
pouvoir créer des emplois, pour pouvoir
améliorer les conditions de vie des
populations, je ne pense pas qu'il y
aurait eu cette immigration euh 60 ans
après les indépendances, mais on a
encouragé
la dictature, on a maintenu des gens au
pouvoir dans euh dans euh finalement
dans leur intérêt.
Quand vous voyez un monsieur comme au F
B,
vous faites 33 ans mais vous êtes dieu
sur terre. Pendant 33 ans, vous n'avez
jamais vous comme ça une voiture de
votre mère. On vient ouvrir la voiture.
Dès que vous sortez euh on fait tout
pour vous. Finalement, on se demande si
vous vous douchez tout seul, si on vous
la pas. Voilà. un peu. Donc des gens
comme ça quand ils sont soutenus et
admirés
pendant 33 ans qu'il restent au pouvoir
et que quelques années après euh euh
les choses ne sont pas comme elles
devaent être. Il faut pas accuser les
jeunes de ces pays-là de partir de de
venir. Donc moi je pense que les
responsabilités sont partagées. Il y a
la responsabilité des pays occidentaux.
Il y a aussi la responsabilité des
dirigeants africains.
Une petite question internet à la volée.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à écrire une
musique comme Tonton d'Améri ? Tonton
d'Améica, c'est voilà, j'ai été inspiré,
je
par le comportement des pays occidentaux
qui
voilà qui font semblant de nous aider
qui font semblant de nous aider et voilà
et alors qu'il ne visent que les
intérêts. Moi je dis la Banque mondiale,
le FM et tout ça c'est comme le sucre.
Voilà. Voilà. on pense que c'est
indispensable. Voilà. Mais bon, quand
vous commencez à boire du thé pendant
pendant un mois sans sucre, vous
finissez par vous en passer. Et donc je
pense que voilà les les euh
voilà je
la question je
Qu'est-ce qui vous a fait écrire Tonton
d'Amérique ?
Ouais, mais c'est c'est juste pour
dénoncer le comportement des des pays
occidentaux. Voilà. pendant les périodes
de crise, on fait semblant de de d'être
devenir en pompier alors que la nuit, on
attise le feu.
Voilà, donc c'est c'est ce qui m'a
inspiré.
Question internet qui est un peu longue
d'ailleurs.
Euh, il y a même pas de point
d'interrogation.
Alors, je vais quand même la lire. C'est
peut-être un commentaire. Quels sont le
ou les pays stables ou suffisamment
organisés et qui peuvent porter
l'avènement de l'Afrique ? Quel pays
sont les têtes de prou ? Les je rajoute
les pointes de diamant. L'invité parle
d'événements et de l'histoire mais ne
distingue pas le départ le terau de
l'émancipation et je suis sûr que
beaucoup est fait pour permettre à
l'Afrique d'exister comme grande
puissance.
Alors, c'est mal écrit mais c'est pas
grave. L'Union africaine me semble être
une organisation forte. Ma question est
celle d'une personne qui n'a aucune idée
claire de l'Afrique. D'ailleurs, on va
lui redemander de reformuler sa
question.
Quel est quel est le terro ? C'est le
Niger, c'est le Mali, c'est c'est le
troisème qui va permettre
de lancer le mouvement de l'émancipation
de l'Afrique ?
Et on espère, on espère que le Mali et
le Nice
inchallah.
Non, moi je suis pas trop inchallah. Euh
voilà, je suis dans le concret et je
pense que voilà, je pense que
on pose des actes et Dieu il accompagne.
Voilà, on pose des actes et Dieu il
accompagne. Et donc euh on espère
aujourd'hui que ces pays-là vont poser
des actes concrets. Bon, ils ont dit
qu'ils vont ils sont sortis de la CDAO.
Pour le moment, ils ont pas encore
expliqué euh
en détail comment les choses vont se
passer sans la CDAO, sans la libre
circulation de la CDAO, sans les
histoires de douanes et cetera, ils
n'ont pas encore expliqué mais bon chez
nous on dit si vous voyez un margou un
crocodile porte
margouya c'est un cafard
c'est non non c'est comme c'est un petit
lézard c'est un petit lézard
qui ressemble au crocodile. Tout vous
voyez un crocodile, je veux parler de
crocodile
parce queils ont presque ils ont la même
forme. Si vous voyez un crocodile porter
un pantalon, c'est qu' il sait où mettre
sa queue. Voilà. Et donc j'espère que
euh voilà ces trois pays vont nous
détailler comment est-ce que les choses
vont se passer. Mais ce qui est sûr, le
fait d'avoir résisté déjà, c'est quelque
chose qui est à saluer.
Maintenant, est-ce que il y a un pays
francophone qui aujourd'hui
donne vraiment de l'espoir, va porter
l'Afrique ? Euh je n'en vois pas
forcément mais je considère aujourd'hui
la gouvernance de ces trois pays comme
une expérimentation, c'està-dire vivre
sans l'Afrique, sans sans les pays, sans
le dictat des pays occidentaux,
euh vivre sans les prêts de la Banque
mondiale, vivre sans les prêts du FMI,
enfin de voilà
sur la dette
et donc vivre sans les ONG parce parce
que toutes les ONG ont été pratiquement
foutus à la porte.
Pourquoi ?
Ben parce que
c'est un repère de service un repère de
service secret.
Non, en fait oui, c'est ce que c'est ce
qui semble. Maintenant, je sais qu'il y
a des ONG qui étaient là aussi pour
aider les populations.
Euh mais en même temps quand je pense
des pays comme la France où il y a des
gens qui dorment dehors, où il y a des
son SDF à Paris
3500 SDF euh où il y a des gens qui qui
ont du mal à joindre les debout
où il y a des enfants qui dorment dans
la rue
il y a des enfants qui dorment dans les
rues dans le froid où il y a des gens
qui ont en tout cas du mal à joindre le
debout
et que des ONG françaises ou américaines
se lèvent pour aller nous donner euh de
l'eau ou bien pour aller nous donner
pour aller nous faire des dons gratuits.
Bon, on se pose quand même des
questions. Voilà. Et je pense que euh et
puis la main qui donne ordonne et puis
la main qui donne, elle peut être vue
comme supérieure.
Voilà. Et donc je pense que c'est tout
ça qui a amené aujourd'hui ces pays-là à
dire aux gens de partir malgré leur
bonne volonté. Et donc euh de toute
façon, personne ne vi de changer
l'Afrique à notre place. Je pense que
tant qu'on va tendre la main et qu'on va
continuer à nous aider, alors celui qui
te donne qui t'aide et finalement que tu
veilles ou pas, c'est lui le boss.
Et donc je pense voilà, c'est un peu
c'est un peu mon avis.
Question internet. Que penses-t-il de
Kemy Sebba ? Kemi est un frère qui se
bat pour euh
pour l'émanicipation de l'Afrique, même
si les discours sont souvent
je trouve souvent les discours un peu
plus un peu forts.
Est-ce que c'est un mercenaire au
service d'autres puissance ? Oh bon, on
n pas de preuves. On n pas de preuves de
ça. Si on n pas de preuves, on peut pas
dire que c'est une puissance qui est
derrière lui. Ça peut être aussi un
jeune qui est qui est ex qui en a marre
que l'Afrique soit maltraitée, qui en a
marre que l'Afrique soit considérée
comme un continent inférieur.
Ça peut être aussi un jeune qui voilà
qui est révolté comme moi. Voilà, je
pense qu'il est révolté comme moi et que
voilà, peut-être que nous avons deux
manières de faire passer notre message
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est
c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui est
beaucoup apprécié aujourd'hui par
beaucoup de jeunes africains. Je pense
que il est très suivi, il est très
soutenu et ça veut dire quelque part que
son combat est positif pour les
Africains. En tout cas, maintenant tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord avec lui.
C'est quelque chose que je peux
comprendre. même moi, voilà, je sais que
euh tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
avec moi et chez nous, on dit il y a que
Dieu qui fait l'unanimité quoi. Que même
Dieu ne fait pas l'unanimité, je veux
dire, parce que voilà que même Dieu ne
fait pas l'unanimité et donc euh voilà
euh il mène son combat, il est apprécié
et voilà je m'arrête là.
Question internet. Bonjour. Pensez-vous
que l'intervention de l'armée française
au Mali a servi quelque chose et
pourquoi ? Mais je pense qu'au début ça
a servi à quelque chose.
Serv à quelque chose.
Oui, je pense qu'au début ça a
l'intervention a servi à quelque chose
puisque ça a permis de stopper l'avancée
des terrorismes vers Bamo. C'est une
réalité. Mais euh voilà mais euh ce
n'était pas prévu que ça dure autant.
quand je vous appelle pour venir m'aider
à libérer mon territoire, euh voilà, ça
veut pas dire dans une autre langue que
euh j'étais appelé à venir t'éterniser
chez moi, que j'étais appelé à venir
finalement commander les opérations
pendant des décennies. Parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir, c'est que quand
l'armée française était sur place, c'est
elle qui dirigeait les opérations sur
notre territoire. Et donc euh et voilà,
je pense que ça a juste servi à à
stopper l'avancée euh des des des des
terroristes vers Bamako. Maintenant euh
je pense que c'est le deuxème plan de la
France qui nous a dérangé, c'est le fait
de s'installer là. Moi, je suis allé à
Gao, je me croyais en Afghanistan à
l'aéroport. La report était contrôlée
par l'armée française et à l'aéroport de
Gao, tu avais le camp des Allemands, le
camp des Hollandais, le camp d'étan,
toute tout Babylone était là, tout
l'Occident était là, je veux dire. Et
donc je pense que l'opération française
a juste contribué à stopper l'avancée
des terroristes. Donc il aurait fallu
tout suite rentrer dans un système de
formation
de l'armée malienne. Et si on voulait
apporter une aide, il fallait tout de
suite apporter ces aidesl en armement.
Et et donc on a compris que non, malgré
toutes les technologies aujourd'hui des
Français
euh voilà, ils ont des radars, ils ont
ils ont des possibilités d'écoute, ils
ont ils peuvent rester à Paris et voir
ce qui se passe dans le nord du Mali,
ils peuvent rester à Paris voir ce qui
se passe dans un domicile
à pardon à à Gao, je veux dire. Et donc
avoir tous ces moyenslà et rester de
2013 à 2021, moi j'ai dit voilà
arrivé un moment et le il fallait il
fallait leur demander de rentrer chez
eux malgré voilà on sait que il y a
beaucoup de jeunes français qui ont qui
ont laissé leur vie et je présente mes
condolances à ces familles là mais le
Mali c'est chez nous le Mali c'est notre
c'est la terre que nos ancêtres nous ont
laissé et c'est comme la France pour les
Français un jour il y a un français qui
peut arriver au pouvoir, qui peut
demander à tous les Africains de rentrer
chez eux. Et donc voilà, on dénoncera ça
mais bon et mais euh le Mali c'est chez
nous, on a décidé que après toutes ces
années toutes ces années, puisque la
France n'a pas trouvé de solution pour
stopper les terroristes, euh on a
demandé qu'il partent et que nous-même
on va se débrouiller. Voilà. Et donc
c'est tout.
Comment Emmanuel Macron est perçu en
Afrique ?
Mais je pense que euh
Emmanuel Macron est perçu comme euh
celui qui nous a aidé à nous réveiller
finalement avec euh euh ce ces ces
discours de donneur de leçon ou de
donneur d'ordre et cetera euh ça crée un
choc.
Et donc voilà euh
je pense que c'est comme ça que beaucoup
de de de d'Africains considèrent
Emmanuel Macron comme voilà quand il dit
par exemple il y a eu tel coup d'état
dans quel tel pays. Alors demain je vais
appeler le président de la CDAO euh pour
lui voilà pour en discuter avec lui.
Mais il a rien à faire. Voilà, le Niger
c'est pas la France, le Mali c'est pas
la France. Et donc je pense qu'il aurait
fallu avoir un discours plus modéré euh
un discours
moins impérialiste pour éviter que ce
que que les Africains soient choqués. Et
donc je pense que voilà, c'est comme ça
que Emmanuel Macron est considéré comme
celui qui nous a réveillé finalement.
Comment ça a été perçu quand il a dit à
un président "Ah, il est parti réparer
la climatisation".
Oui. Oui.
Tu te rappelles de ça ?
Ben, ça a été considéré comme une
fouise, ça a été considéré comme un
manque de respect
et voilà. Et il s'est pas trompé. Vous
savez, quelqu'un qui vous fait ça en
public, ça veut dire que au téléphone,
c'est c'est le chef, quoi. Ça veut dire
que la le le le au téléphone, il doit se
mettre à l'aise parce que s'il a eu le
courage de faire ça,
c'est peut-être une blague manquée.
Non, je pense que quand on est président
d'un pays, euh
tous les mots doivent être mesurés,
surtout quand vous êtes en visite dans
un autre pays. Euh voilà, les blagues
doivent rester dans le salon à l'Élysée
euh ou dans les cafés quoi, mais pas
là-bas. Et donc je pense que
c'est cette habitude
d'être le chef finalement des présidents
de pays francophones, voilà, qui est
ressorti et qui a été très très mal pris
par tous les africains. Voilà, je pense
que tout le monde a mais tout ça ça nous
a choqué. Je pense c'est tout ça qui
nous a réveillé. On se dit "Mais mais il
y a un problème ? Comment un président
d'un autre pays
peut avoir un de langage dans notre pays
devant notre président et contre notre
président ?" Donc voilà, je pense que
Emmanuel Macron a contribué en tout cas
au au réveil de de l'Afrique
aujourd'hui.
On a vu que l'Afrique quand Barack Obama
a été élu, ça
a été un grand mouvement. euh de voir un
un président Black à la tête des
États-Unis. Hm
hm.
Comment Trump, comment Biden sont perçu
sur le continent.
Barack Obama d'abord c'était
les africains étaient contents
puis ils ont vite déchanté c'est ça ?
Il y en a qui ont déchanté moi pas. Moi
pas parce que pour moi la mission de
Barack Obama le fait d'abord
qu'un black soit à la maison blanche
pour moi c'est historique.
Pour moi euh
Barack Obama ne pouvait pas changer les
injustices contre les noirs aux
États-Unis. ça allait créer d'autres
problèmes. Et donc le fait que déjà
Barack Obama était à la Maison Blanche
pour moi c'est historique. Pour moi, je
suis heureux d'avoir vécu pour voir ça
parce que je pense que 5 ou 10 ans avant
ceux qui sont morts, si on les réveille
pour dire "Réveillez-vous, il y a un
noir à la maison blanche, ils vont dire
"Mais attends, laisse-moi dormir, c'est
pas possible." Voyez un peu.
Voilà. Donc pour moi, c'est ça qui était
important et ça c'est arrivé. Ça c'est
arrivé. maintenant Trompe, il a dit
America first, il a dit Amérique
d'abord.
Je pense que ça a été perçu par beaucoup
d'Africains qui n'avaient qui ne
comprenaient pas les choses parce que
pourquoi des gens étaient choqués ? Il y
en a qui ont dit "Non, les aides
américaines vont s'arrêter euh tout va
être tous les robinets vont être fermés
mais en fait il faut que les robinets
soient fermés pour que nous on se prenne
en charge
pour que nous on soit vraiment
indépendant. Il faut qu'on soit pas
dépendant des aides américaines et
cetera. Voyez un peu
Biden.
Biden,
je pense que aujourd'hui l'Afrique
actuelle considère Biden comme un
président américain et n'atarien de
Biden.
Euh vous savez le cas de Kaddafi, si
c'est Trump qui était au pouvoir, je
pense pas que Trump allait attaquer
Kaddafi. Je ne pense pas parce qu'il a
dit America first. Donc ce que vous
faites là-bas, je ne pense pas que Trump
allait contribuer d'ailleurs pendant
pendant son règne. Je pense qu'il y a eu
moins d'attaques des États-Unis contre
les autres pays. Vous voyez un peu, je
pense que ça c'est ce que nous en tant
que africain conscient, on retient dans
la gouvernance des de Trump, c'est que
il s'est pas trop mêlé de ce qui s'est
passé en Afrique.
Tu as pas peur en fait que ce que tu me
décris soit un peu le rebond du chat
mort ? C'est-à-dire,
c'est-à-dire
l'unification du continent arrivera trop
tard, le réchauffement climatique va
tout balayer
et que et que ça va être archi archi dur
et que ce sera trop tard.
Mais j'espère que l'unification ne sera
pas trop tard. À partir du moment où on
a compris que c'est l'Union qui fait la
force, à partir du moment où on a
compris que l'Afrique unie gagnera
beaucoup de combats, il faut aller vers
l'unité. Il faut pas attendre 100 ans
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure, il faut
pas attendre 50 ans. Je pense que il
faut accélérer le rapprochement.
Euh on n pas le choix. Si on veut une
autre Afrique, si on veut que nos
enfants vivent dans une autre Afrique,
il faut accélérer certains processus. Et
moi, c'est ce que je chante depuis des
années et c'est ce que je vais continuer
à chanter. Il faut, il y a aucune
solution aujourd'hui. L'Afrique unie
avec toutes les matières premières dont
on dispose, on sera obligé de le monde
entier sera obligé de nous écouter et
et tu vois pas ça différemment. Ils vont
peut-être attendre que le continent se
fasse ravager par le réchauffement
climatique. Ils seront tous construits
des murs en attendant que les africains
se fassent manger par les moi, je pense
qu'il est temps
par les menaces du siècle. En fait, il
est temps d'arrêter de d'accuser à
partir du moment où on sait
Tu comprends ? Tu comprends que je me
fasse l'avocat du diable ?
Ouais, je comprends ? Ouais. Il est
temps d'arrêter d'accuser. À partir du
moment où nous-même on connaît
l'importance
de
de de de ce qui on est capable de faire,
il faut le faire tout de suite. Il faut
le faire. Il faut pas attendre. Moi, je
pense que il faut se rapprocher, il faut
aller vers l'unité.
Et et je pense que l'unité ne viendra
pas forcément des dirigeants, mais ça
viendra des peuples. Il faut que les
peuples comprennent l'importance de
cette unité là et qu'elle et que le
peuple poussent les dirigeants à aller
vers l'unité.
Voilà, il faut aller vite et c'est ce
que je chante et c'est ce que je c'est
de ça que je parle tout le temps. Je
pense que les autres évidemment vous
savez tout le monde se bat pour apporter
à manger à ses enfants. Voilà, quand on
se lève le matin pour aller bosser,
c'est pour que le sac de riz soit à la
maison, qu'il y ait du pain pour les
enfants et cetera et donc les
occidentaux jusqu'à la fin du monde, ils
se battront pour que leur population ait
l'eau, l'électricité
et cetera. Maintenant, à nous de faire
la même chose à partir du moment où on
sait que euh si on se met ensemble avec
toutes nos matières premières, qu'on
sera écouté, qu'on sera plus respecté,
donc il faut y aller vite. Il faut pas
attendre. Moi, je pense que le temps des
accusations est presque révolue
maintenant à partir du moment où le
monde est ouvert, qu'on peut tout voir
et que chacun a sa télé, qu'on peut
s'exprimer.
Si on peut s'exprimer avec sa télé, ça
veut dire qu'on peut parler d'unité, ça
veut dire qu'on peut parler de
d'importance, de l'importance de
l'unité, ça veut dire qu'on peut parler
de rapprochement. Ça veut dire que on
peut euh dire un peu ouvertement ce qui
est positif pour nous. Donc euh les
occidentaux
euh politiquement feront les choses pour
toujours mettre la couverture sur eux à
nous de dire non. Vous savez une grande
partie des Français ont l'électricité
grâce à l'uranium du Niger.
Alors le Niger,
l'endroit où l'uranium est exploité, il
y a pas d'hôpitaux. L'espérience de vie,
c'est 40 ou 45 ans là-bas. Il y a pas
d'hôpitaux, pas de route. En fait,
aucune condition n'a été créée pour que
les gens qui vivent dans cette zone là
soient épargnés des maladies
et une bonne éducation et cetera et
cetera. On a préféré mettre l'accent sur
l'exploitation du de l'uranium et
cetera. Et donc, c'est au peuple
nigérien du Niger, pardon, je veux dire,
de
réclamer sa part du gâteau ou de mettre
le haut là. dit OK voilà vous voulez
l'uranium désormais il y a pas de
problème nous on a l'uranium
voilà on veut le blé vous savez c'est à
vérifier et les internautes peuvent
vérifier en 1960
il y a un contrat de 76 ans qui a été
signé entre la France et le Niger et
pendant les 76 ans, la France elle pour
exploiter ce qu'elle veut et donner le
pourcentage du Niger crois qu'au début
c'était 15 % je crois qu'aujourd'hui on
doit on doit être autour de 20 à 21
Vous voyez un peu ? Et donc si vous
regardez le Niger, vous trouvez que
c'est l'un des pays où il y a eu plus de
coups d'état parce que chaque fois qu'un
président arrive qui pose des questions,
boum boum, vous voyez un peu ? Et donc
euh l'Occident continuera à trouver du
pain pour ses enfants et à nous de
réclamer notre part et personne ne
viendra réclamer ça à notre place. C'est
notre peuple et nos dirigeants qui
doivent prendre position pour que le
gâteau soit partagé équitablement. Et je
pense que nous en tant que propriétaire
naturel de ces matières premières, nous
devons avoir la plus grande partie du
gâteau.
On voit que la France, bon, elle est pas
trop en odeur de sainteté en Afrique.
Est-ce que tu penses que c'est à cause
d'un mauvais renseignement de terrain,
de mauvais capteur, de mauvaise remonté
d'information ou tout simplement un
mauvais cap que la France a pris ?
pour son partenariat avec l'Afrique.
Est-ce que tu penses que certains
cabinets de X ou Y
cabinet français censé faire de
l'ingérence en Afrique, ils sont
totalement plantés et qu'ils ont pas su
voir, ils n'ont pas su reconnaître qu'il
fallait changer ?
Ouais. Je pense que ils
ont pas compris que
les les que ils n'ont pas compris que
les les
périodes ont changé, que les Africains
se sont réveillés. Je pense qu'ils ont
Comment il fait l'africain pour
s'informer ?
Ben l'africain aujourd'hui s'informe à
travers les réseaux sociaux. Les
africains aujourd'hui s'informent avec
cette interview ce soir
avec cette interview ce soir par exemple
il y a beaucoup qui vont apprendre des
choses et les africains tous les
africains ont aujourd'hui des téléphones
portables, ils vont sur YouTube, ils
vont sur Facebook, ils vont un peu
partout. Donc c'est comme ça que je
pense que c'est euh l'événement
d'Internet qui a changé tout ça parce
que euh le système français en Afrique
euh n'a pas vu ça venir. Ils n'ont pas
vu les choses venir. Et donc voilà, ils
ont été débordés et
donc aujourd'hui ce divorce là, vous
savez, dans un divorce, il y a toujours
un qui n'est pas du tout content. Je
veux dire bon ça arrive que
les enfants
voilà et les enfants
c'est ça
et donc je pense que aujourd'hui il y a
un divorce
et que il y a une partie qui refuse
d'accepter ce divorce là et que il y a
une partie qui refuse de voir les
réalités
euh une partie qui refuse d'accepter que
l'autre a compris comme j'ai chanté on a
tout compris aujourd'hui.
Les africains ont compris que une autre
Afrique est possible. Maintenant, nous
cherchons la manière d'aller vers cette
autre Afrique.
Tu parles des réseaux sociaux. Est-ce
que les réseaux sociaux aussi ils ont
pas un peu manipulé les africains, la
population africaine ? Deux exemples, la
propagation de la rumeur,
tu sais ce que c'est
par les réseaux sociaux où il y a des
expédition punitive qui vont dans un
village parce qu'ils ont vu un albinos
ou ils ont entendu parler d'un albinos
qui était possédé par le démon. Ça fait
ça aussi les réseaux sociaux en Afrique.
Ouais, je suis d'accord. Les réseaux
sociaux ont été
c'est un instrument
qui est salutaire pour nous, qui voilà
qui nous apporte beaucoup qui nous a
beaucoup apporté. Mais en même temps,
nous l'avons nous l'utilisons mal le
fait qu'on l'utilise pour s'insulter
euh le fait qu'on l'utilise pour diviser
alors que nous avons besoin d'unité.
Et voilà et les rumeurs comme vous avez
dit parce qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
sur internet qui ne sont pas vraies. Et
donc voilà, je vais vous donner un
exemple. euh par exemple euh euh
la Côte d'Ivoire Balom Mali et il y a un
monsieur qui vient qui vient dit que euh
dans les années 70 euh euh il y a un
marabou qui a fait un sacrifice pour le
Mali et que euh le Mali n'a pas respecté
son engagement envers ce envers ce
marabou, que c'est pourquoi et que
c'était une situation entre la Côte
d'Ivoire et le Mali, que le Mali n'a pas
respecté son engagement, que c'est
pourquoi le Mali a du mal à vendre à à
battre la Côte d'Ivoire,
tu vois. Et donc il y a quelqu'un qui
m'a raconté ça, j'ai dit "Non, nous on a
vu le match. Voilà, c'est vrai que le
Mali a super bien joué. Le Mali a un jeu
qui est plus intéressant que celui de la
Côte d'Ivoire. Mais bon, le football n'a
pas de règles. S'il y avait des règles
précises, je pense pas que la Mauritanie
allait battre l'Algérie.
Vous voyez un peu. Et donc c'est la
rumeur. Je pense que euh
cet instrument à les réseaux sociaux. Si
nos parents
juste après l'indépendance, ceux qui
étaient prêts à libérer totalement
l'Afrique, s'ils avaient eu les réseaux
sociaux, je pense qu'ils allaient gagner
le combat. Et donc nous devons
considérer cet instrument comme un
salut, comme
euh euh quelque chose qui nous a
réveillé et l'utiliser positivement au
lieu de nous insulter, au lieu de
continuer à à à encourager la division
alors que nous avons besoin du contraire
de la division. Effectivement, je suis
d'accord avec vous. Les réseaux sociaux
sont mal utilisés. Voilà.
Avec toi. Hm
hm.
Tu parles de la Cann coupe d'Afrique des
nations. Est-ce que tu penses quand la
Coupe d'Afrique des nations serait un
peu passé, il y a les vrais problèmes
qui vont remonter parce que là tout le
monde est en apesanteur avec la canne et
là on va voir vraiment des choses
difficiles ?
Ah oui, bien sûr, bien sûr. Vous savez,
c'est comme un peu partout, hein. Euh
voilà.
Tu as entendu parler du génocide là qui
est en train de se passer c'est dans
quel pays, dis-moi ? Euh
Congo
euh je sais que le Goma est encerclé
mais je connais pas les détails.
Je pas les détails.
Voilà. Mais effectivement après la CANN
les vrais voilà on va s'attaquer au
vrais problèmes. On va les problèmes
vont les gens vont continuer à à
voilà on va on va s'attaquer
au vrai problème. Je pense que la canne
va pas durer éternellement mais les gens
ils attendent effectivement avec les
médias.
Voilà, la CAN fait oublier des choses
mais je pense que le lendemain de la
finale lorsque le gagnant de la Coupe
d'Afrique va finir de fêter sa victoire
alors les les problèmes vont revenir et
puis les gens vont continuer le combat
pour que pour que les des solutions
soient trouvées.
Question internet, vous ne citez jamais
directement les personnes dans votre
musique. Est-ce un choix artistique ou
une protection contre les diffamations ?
Non, je ne cite pas le nom. Le noms que
je cite très souvent, c'est des gens qui
sont morts pour la voilà. Donc si
quelqu'un veut avoir son nom euh dans ma
musique, il faut qu'elle pose des actes
euh ou des actes. Tu vois, par exemple,
je veux un conseil au Burkina et puis il
y en a qui sont il y a quelqu'un qui me
dit "Mais tu as pas chanté le capitaine
Trauré ?" J'ai dis "Mais le capitaine
Traoré, il n'a pas encore accompli sa
mission. Moi je vais voir la fin du film
avant de le chanter." Voilà un peu
voilà, il y en a qui disent "Mais tu
parles pas d'Assimi Goita ?" J'ai dit
"Non, moi j'attends la fin du film.
C'est à la fin du film que je vais faire
une conclusion et que l'inspiration va
venir. Et donc c'est un peu ça. Sinon,
moi j'ai chanté Thomas Sankara, Patrice
Lumumba, Quam Kruma euh par rapport à la
fin de leur film, les actes qu'ils ont
posé jusqu'à la fin de leur vie et donc
voilà euh c'est un peu ça et ça c'est le
reget. Il y a des musiques qui sont
faites pour chanter les louanges des
gens
qui attendent de l'argent en retour et
puis il y a des musiques qui sont fait
pour éveiller le consciences.
Donc moi en tant que régume, il y a une
chose que je déteste, c'est quand je
suis sur scène qu'on vient me donner de
l'argent. Ça, je déteste. J'aime pas.
J'aime pas du tout. Et je pense que ceux
qui me connaissent savent que j'aime pas
ça parce que le regret, c'est pas une
musique commerciale. Il y en a qui en
ont fait une musique commerciale mais
moi je suis sur la ligne tracée par Bob
Marley. C'est cette ligne radicale qui a
décidé de continuer à défendre les
peuples et à parler pour la majorité des
peuples qui n'ont pas de voix.
Question internet d'ailleurs qui va
faire l'avocat du diable à ma place.
Bravo à Ticken pour ses chansons et ses
messages. Par contre, lui qui se dit
panafricanisme,
pourquoi est-il inscrit à la Sassem et
peau au bureau des droits d'auteur
ivoiriens ?
Ben, je suis inscrit, la personne doit
se renseigner, je suis inscrit au bureau
de droits d'hôtel ivoirien et à
l'assassem. Voilà à l'assassin parce que
je fais des concerts en France parce que
voilà je travaille des musiciens
français parce que voilà une grande
partie de ma carrière est en France donc
euh je me suis inscrit à l'assassin pour
euh pour que l'assassin puisse défendre
mon sac de riz. Voilà donc euh mais la
personne doit se renseigner. Je suis
inscrit au Burdauda. Vous savez euh au
moment où l'assassin me donne par
exemple me paye 40 millions de francs
CFA, quand combien en euros ?
Euh je crois que ça doit être autour de
45 ou 50000 €. Euh quand je vais dans la
même période au Burda j'ai 1500 €. Donc
voilà. Heureusement que je suis à la
zazem d'ailleurs.
Donc voilà, la personne doit savoir que
ça c'est du
c'est normal, c'est ce que j'ai fait. Le
fait de m'inscrire à l'assassem, c'est
ce que je devais faire.
Est-ce qu'on peut être rasta et musulman
en même temps ?
Euh, je pense je pense que on peut être
rasta et musulman, Rasta et chrétien et
cetera. Je pense que le rasta, c'est
celui qui se bat pour la justice,
l'égalité
et qui euh voilà pour moi le le voilà et
qui cultive l'amour
et voilà pour moi le rasta, tu peux être
musulman ou chrétien et être rasta.
Voilà, pour moi, il y a pas de il y a
pas de problème. Maintenant, il faut
demander aux vrais Rasta qui ont des
églises Rasta euh s'il est possible de
d'aller dans l'église Rasta et aller à
la mosquée. Et je pense qu'ils vont vous
répondre. Et puis bon, moi je dis hein
euh euh
Rasta c'est super parce que c'est
Blackman qui a créé Rastafaray,
le rastafarisme, je veux dire.
Alors que euh toutes ces autres
religions sont venues d'ailleurs. Euh
Mahomé n'est pas black, Jésus n'est pas
black. Euh voilà, on a reçu des
messages. D'ailleurs, ces religions ont
été imposées quelquefois par la chicote
ou par le sac de riz. Vous savez quand
les missionnaires sont venus, on
entretenait une famille. Voilà, on leur
donnait le sac de riz, on habillait les
enfants. Comme ça, quand les autres du
village voient ça, ils vont à l'église.
Voilà. comme ça, il peut bénéficier du
sac de riz et des habits. Euh euh on
parle de Samoretouré en tant que
résistant français mais sinon c'était un
jihadiste parce que lui il ravageait,
lui c'était il cassait, il détruisait
carrément les villes qui ne voulaient
pas se soumettre à l'islam, qui ne
voulaient pas se convertir. Et donc
c'est comme ça que les religions sont
arrivées en Afrique. Donc moi je suis
croyant mais je ne suis le porte-parole
d'aucune religion.
C'est quoi ton point de vue sur le
cannabis ?
Ben, je pense que c'est une cit c'est
c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il disait Bob Marley sur le
cannabis ?
Mais ils disent que il disait que
l'herbe est une plante que c'est c'est
la c'est une plante voilà qui est
naturelle et donc et qui doit être fumé
et qui fait pas autant de mal dont on
comme on on le dit. Moi, je dis il faut
laisser la liberté aux gens de euh
de fumer la cigarette ou de fumer le
cannabis, mais il faut pas forcément le
légaliser en Afrique, par exemple. Moi,
je suis pas contre la légalisation, mais
je suis contre le fait qu'on réprime
quelqu'un qui fume un joint
et et donc je suis contre ça. Alors que
euh à Paris, vous allez tomber sur des
gens qui fument un joint dans les rues
qui sont libres.
Non non non non.
Voilà. Euh
le cannabis à Paris, c'est plus le
cannabis de Bob Marley, c'est des c'est
de la drogue dure maintenant.
Bon donc voilà. Mais en tout cas, je
sais que c'est moins dangereux en Europe
que en Afrique, par exemple. Et ça, je
condamne. Je condamne le fait que
Pourquoi c'est dangereux en Afrique ?
Ben
parce que ça fait des rebelles partout.
Ça fait des rebelles et puis euh voilà,
c'est considéré comme une drogue d
finalement. Voilà. Et alors que la
cigarette final la cigarette fait plus
de mal et je pense que
la cigarette
fait plus de mal puisqueil y a la
nicotine et cetera et donc moi je pense
que et puis il y a trop de d'hypocrisie.
La plupart des politiques qui ont étudié
en France aux États-Unis je pense que la
nuit doivent fumer un joint avant
d'aller au lit ou
peut-être plus.
Ouais. On les appelle les ninjas. Ouais.
Les ninjas.
Ouais. Ouais.
Tu parles de Babylone.
Ouais.
Pour les Rastas, ça a une grosse grosse
signification quand Babylone
s'effondrera s'effondrera.
Mais Babylone, c'est le système et elle
n'est pas seulement le système n'est pas
seulement occidental.
un système qui qui qui fait de la
répression sur son peuple, un système
qui qui fait de la corruption, un
système corrompu, je veux dire un
système euh qui a créé une dictature,
c'est aussi Babylone.
Voilà, c'est pas seulement l'Occident,
c'est
voilà, c'est Babylone. Bob Marley
appelait le gouvernement jamaïcain
Babylone. Donc c'est plutôt, c'est pas
le blanc, c'est pas le noir, c'est un
système qui est dénoncé. le système qui
est dénoncé qu'on appelle Babylone en
général.
Je t'ai posé des questions sur euh
Macron. Comment Macron était perçu ?
Comment Biden était perçu ? Comment
Trump était perçu ? Comment Obama était
perçu ? Hm
hm.
Maintenant comment Sie Ping est perçu et
comment Poutine est perçu par le
continent ? Bon euh, écoutez, par le
continent, en général, ces deux
personnes sont considérées comme des
gens qui ont tenu tête à l'Occident,
qui ont stoppé un peu la suprématie de
l'Occident.
Et donc euh certains africains ont une
certaine
euh estime euh voilà
euh ils sont voilà, ils apprécient. Euh
moi je dis je ne suis ni putist
poutiniste ni euh ni voilà chinois le
président chinois puisque c'est des pays
dans leur pays il y a pas de démocratie
il y a pas de liberté d'expression
totalement et on a vu euh comment quel
que soit euh le comportement des
Prigogin hein en Russie on sait que Euh
c'était quelqu'un de pas bien, mais la
manière dont il est mort, moi j'ai pas
envie
que que que les opposants soient tués
comme ça là-bas en Afrique. Et donc il y
a une journaliste qui a été tuée Anna
quelque chose qui a été tué en Russie.
Ça n'a jamais été lucidé. Il y a jamais
eu d'enquête. l'enquête n'a jamais
abouti. Il y a un opposant qui a été
abattu sur un pont pas loin du cremblin.
Et donc c'est des choses que je combats
en Afrique. Et donc euh tant que ces
dirigeants vont vont pas libérer la
parole et cetera, moi je ne serai pas je
vais jamais les applaudir. Je dis que
aujourd'hui les Africains euh ont un peu
d'estime pour ces dirigeants-là par
rapport au chamboulement qu'ils ont créé
parce que c'est ce
fait qu'ils ont tenu tête à l'Occident
que aujourd'hui on a des gens comme
Assimi Goita, on a des gens comme le
capitaine Traoré, on a des gens comme le
président du Niger qui aujourd'hui
s'expriment ouvertement, prennent
position ouvertement et donc euh je
pense que c'est pourquoi beaucoup
d'Africains des certains Africains
apprécient celaux. là, mais ce n'est pas
tous les africains.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses des gens
qui pratiquent
une chose qui est qualifiée par d'autres
qui s'appelle l'appropriation culturelle
?
C'est-à-dire,
moi j'ai pas le droit de m'habiller, me
faire des dreadlocks. J'ai pas le droit
de de me revendiquer de X ou Y parce que
ça vient de l'Afrique et j'ai pas le
droit de m'en inspirer et j'ai pas le
droit de me l'approprier. Qu'est-ce que
tu penses de ça ?
Je pense c'est la culture. Les gens
voilà,
si moi j'ai envie de m'habiller avec mon
boubou,
mais je pense que vous avez le droit. Au
contraire, au contraire, vous vous
habillez dans un boubou. Alors
automatiquement
je mettre un Sarwel,
ben automatiquement vous si vous
habillez dans un boubou, alors vous
faites la publicité de l'Afrique.
Que c'est comme ça que je vois les
choses. Voilà, je pense que rien qu'avec
les habits, l'Afrique peut attirer
l'attention du monde entier. Imaginez
une journée de l'Afrique
et pendant cette journée que tout le
monde s'habille en appui traditionnel.
Vous imaginez la couleur, l'image,
euh le confort,
le confort et et surtout cette journée,
elle fera travailler tous les artisans
africains pendant toute une année. Vous
voyez un peu. Et donc euh moi je pense
que la culture, voilà, quelqu'un qui
veut s'adapter à la culture d'un pays
africain ou d'un Moi, je je ne vois rien
contre ça. Moi, je suis pas du tout
contre ça. Au contraire, quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse à ma culture
pour moi, c'est une forme de respect. Ça
veut dire que la personne me respecte et
donc je ne peux pas combattre ça.
Comment c'est perçu en Afrique que
l'Europe et d'autres pays exportent ses
déchets
et que c'est des gamins qui se mettent à
quatre pattes pour faire cramer du des
fils électriques pour récupérer du
cuivre ou qui récupère des composants
sur des télés ou qui a des vieilles
affaires qui débarquent en Afrique.
Comment ça se passe ? Ben l'Afrique est
devenue effectivement la poubelle du
monde. Les gens, ils viennent des
vieilles voitures. C'est pourquoi euh
j'ai apprécier que le fait que certains
pays ont mis des limites. Il y a des
pays où une voiture de moins de 15 ans
ne peut pas entrer.
Voilà. Et donc
de plus de 15 ans
de Ouais. Une voiture de plus de 15 ans,
je veux dire, ne peut pas ne doit pas
rentrer. Et donc moi, c'est quelque
chose que j'apprécie. Je pense que
il faut que ça ça s'arrête, il faut
qu'on stoppe ça. C'est vrai que la
pauvreté fait que beaucoup de personnes
ne peut pas s'acheter des nouvelles
voitures, beaucoup de personnes ne peut
pas s'acheter des nouvelles télés et
cetera, mais
je pense que dans l'avenir, il faut il
faut trouver une solution pour arrêter
ça, pour éviter que l'Afrique en tout
cas ne continue à être la poubelle du
monde. Comment tu fais quand tu as faim
et que tu es tout nu pour dire non ?
C'est difficile. Je pense que c'est
difficile et c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui
euh
les gens acceptent tout ce qui se passe,
tout ce qui vient sur l'Afrique. Je
pense que c'est un peu compliqué
de dire non quand on est nu. Je veux
dire, comme je le dis dans tonton
d'Amérique, mais euh
il faut se rendre compte que ces déchets
ne font pas du bien à l'Afrique et que
ça tue. Quand vous arrivez à Bamako que
vous circulez dans les rues, vous voyez
la fumée de toutes ces vieilles
voitures, toutes ces motos mélanger avec
la poussière. Je pense pas que ça fait
du bien au poumon. Et donc ça fait que
les hôpitaux sont pleins. Partout en
Afrique, les hôpitaux sont pleins parce
que il y a rien qui contrôlé. le poisson
qui vient de la Chine, euh le riz qui
vient de la Thaïlande. Euh alors qu'on a
des terres cultivables, on a des bras
valides et donc je pense qu'il faut que
tout ça change et personne ne viendra
apporter cees changements à notre place.
Il faut que les populations poussent les
dirigeants à prendre des décisions qui
puissent éviter que l'Afrique ne
continue à être une poubelle de
l'Afrique sur le plan alimentaire, sur
le plan euh euh technologique aussi, sur
le plan voilà.
La première fois qu'on s'est rencontré,
c'était il y a 15 ans à Mayotte.
À Mayotte ? Ouais.
Tu as été plusieurs fois à Mayotte. Hm
hm.
Est-ce que tu es au courant de la
situation à Mayotte
avec les mecs qui font des attaques à la
machette, la grande délinquence,
les les gangs, les bus scolaires qui se
font attaquer ? Hm hm.
Oui, j'ai suivi un peu un moment le
rapatriement des Comoriens
qui vivent sur le sol Maoré
et pour moi c'est
voilà, je dirais que c'est vous savez le
peuple de de
Mayotte et le peuple du Comora, c'est un
seul peuple, c'est la même famille.
Et moi, j'ai l'habitude de dire quand je
suis là-bas en concert, j'ai dit que si
la France veut vraiment
améliorer,
développer Mayotte,
il faut qu'elle fasse,
je ne dirais pas qu'elle fasse la même
chose pour le comor et
il a un référendum. Voilà, il y a eu un
référendum, ils ont décidé d'être à la
France mais sauf que il va être
difficile de développer Mayotte,
d'équiper Mayot, de créer des emplois en
Mayotte et laisser le com de côté. Ça va
être pratiquement impossible. C'est à
peu près ce qui se passe avec le
continent africain et l'Europe.
C'est ce qui se passe. C'est ce qui
s'est passé d'ailleurs pendant ces 60
ans de soi-disant indépendance, c'est
que l'Europe a continué à se développer
et elle n'a pas fait, je veux dire,
voilà, elle n'a pas fait à au pays
qu'ils ont colonisé. Il aurait fallu euh
euh euh pas, je ne dirais pas aider mais
utiliser les richesses produites
produites par les pays africains pour
aider l'Afrique à se développer.
Je te pose la même question, mais elle
est reposée sur internet. Que pens-il
que pensez-vous du repli de l'Occident
vers des partis d'extrême droite en
désignant les migrants comme le les mots
de l'Europe, les mots des États-Unis ?
Bon, je pense que les gens ne
connaissent pas tous les détails en
fait. les migrants
jouent un rôle très très important dans
euh le développement de l'Europe. Vous
savez, même à Paris, si vous faites un
sondage, vous rentrez dans les
restaurants alors qu'on sait que tous
les les restaurants sont pleins à midi,
hein. Allez-y dans la cuisine. Vous
trouverez toujours un malien, un
Ivoirien,
en tout cas, il y a un cuisinier qui est
là. et vous allez dans beaucoup de
secteurs aujourd'hui. Vous trouverez un
algérien ou un africain. Donc je pense
que le système français sait qu'il y a
des sans papiers qui travaillent mais
il a besoin d'eux. Donc il ferme les
yeux et donc je pense que si
l'immigration s'arrête totalement euh
l'Europe aura du mal à continuer son
développement puisque vous avez une
population vieillissante.
Alors vous avez forcément besoin de bras
jeunes et valides pour continuer à faire
avancer vos pays. Et donc euh c'est ces
ces politiques qui dénoncent
euh cette l'immigration ne maîtrise pas
tout. Je pense que le jour qu'ils
viendront aux affaires, c'est là qu'ils
vont se rendre compte qu'en fait il y
avait un besoin d'avoir des immigrés
ici.
Question internet.
Pourquoi selon lui l'Asie a-t-elle
réussi son décollage économique après la
période de colonisation, domination
occidentale et pas l'Afrique ?
Mais parce que l'Asie a mis l'accent sur
le travail.
Tout le monde sait hein que les
asiatiques aiment travailler
et l'un des défauts des africains, c'est
qu'on n'aime pas le travail.
On on n'aime pas, on fait pas, je ne je
ne réalise pas du tout, mais je dis que
euh l'Asie, tout le monde sait que ça
bosse, que ça fait travailler la tête,
que ça crée ça crée des choses pour
faire avancer le monde. Et je pense que
la différence c'est ça. Vous savez, en
1960, la Corée la Corée du Sud
était au même niveau de développement
que la Côte d'Ivoire, au même niveau
actuellement. Mais aujourd'hui, je crois
que Samsung c'est la Corée du Sud si je
me trompe pas et comparativement à la
Côte d'Ivoire, qu'est-ce que la Côte
d'Ivoire a créé des gales à Samsung ? Et
c'est ça la question. Je pense que c'est
la différence a été au niveau des
politiques de voilà au moment où euh
où nous on vénérait au feu de boigni euh
il fait pas les choses comme on veut
mais c'était le vieux, c'était le père
de tout le monde. Les Coréens mettaient
sûrement la pression sur leurs
dirigeants.
Donc euh voilà, les dirigeants, les
Coréens luttaient forcément contre la
corruption. On a vu des premiers
ministres arrêtés en Corée. Euh, on a vu
des chefs d'état arrêtés et cetera. Ça
c'est des choses qui était impossible
chez nous et qui sont jusqu'à présent
impossibles parce qu'il y a pas de
justice, parce qu'il y a pas d'égalité,
parce que il y a pas de pression sur les
sur les dirigeants. Je pense que euh la
différence c'est ça.
Combien tu as créé d'écoles ? Moi, j'ai
créé six écoles. Une école au Burkina
Faso, un collège au Mali, euh une école
primaire en Guinée Cononakri, une école
au Niger dans la région de Tilabé et la
dernière école a été construite en
Guinée Cononakri et j'ai construit deux
écoles primères en Côte d'Ivoire. Voilà,
le but c'était vraiment de c'est
vraiment de d'encourager l'éducation
parce que pour moi, je pense que
l'éducation va aider beaucoup au réveil
de l'Afrique. Je pense que quand la
majorité des africains sera l et écrit,
les gens iront pas voter pour des
t-shirts. Les gens n'iront pas voter
parce que le candidat vient de mon
village. Les gens n'iront pas voter
parce qu'on m'a donné 2000 francs CFA.
les gens n'iront pas voter parce que
parce qu'on m'a donné un sac de riz
parce que jusqu'à présent c'est ce qui
se passe. C'est la subordination de vote
à tous les étages
et c'est ça. Je pense que dans tous les
pays africains, il faut voter une loi
pour interdire que les voies soient
achetées, que les candidats donnent de
l'argent et je pense que c'est ça va
contribuer à à changer les choses.
Avant que tu chantes, j'ai deux
dernières questions qui ne sont pas des
questions. Hm
hm. Je voudrais que tu me donnes trois
livres à lire qui ont été importants
pour toi et je voudrais que tu me donnes
un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Ben, les trois livres, je dirais
euh il y a euh le livre France-Afrique,
il y a un livre qui s'intitule
France-Afrique. a été écrit par François
Xavier Verchav
qui était le fondateur de l'association
survie qui a beaucoup fait pour nous
mais qui est m connu parce que c'est qui
est qui n'est pas connu parce que c'est
un blanc mais c'est quelqu'un qui est
mort étant en procès avec certains chefs
d'état africains comme Sasou Ngesso et
cetera.
Il était en procès parce qu'il était
poursuivi pour avoir dénoncé le
comportement de ses chefs d'état.
Et le deuxème livre c'est Sunjata Keita
qui a été écrit par Tamsi Niang je crois
qui m'a permis de découvrir un peu
l'histoire du Manding
et le 3è livre c'est le premier
Mandin
l'histoire du Mandin de l'empire du
Mandin où j'ai entendu parler de Sunata
Keita euh où j'étais d'ailleurs fier
parce que à un moment on parle de mon
ancêtre Fakoli Kumba Facoli Daba
le guerrier
le guerrier qui a été très important
dans la dans la dans la guerre de
libération du peuple mandin
et le livre s'appellejata l'épopé
Mandeng ça s'appelle l'épopé Mandeng et
le 3ème livre c'est le premier Rasta qui
a été écrit par euh la journaliste
spécialiste de regé Hélène Lee voilà qui
voilà qui qui a parlé un peu de
l'origine du rastafarisme
euh qui dans ce livre parle du du
premier homme qui s'est réclamé d'être
rastin en jamaïque qui avait créé un
village à quelques kilomètres de
Kingston
où toute la communauté Rasta s'est
retrouvé et il cultivait pour
ravitailler la ville de Kingston en
produits vivriers
et euh bon en même temps les Rasta il
cultivaient euh le cannabis à côté et le
gouvernement jamaicain a profité du fait
qu'il cultivait le cannabis pour
détruire le village Et ce monsieur a été
en procès plusieurs fois euh contre le
avec le gouvernement jamaïcain. Et donc
euh le premier Rasta écrit par Hélè Lee
et euh le livre France-Afrique écrit par
euh François Avsa
et et puis lespopé du Mandin, Djibril
Tamsi quelque chose. Voilà.
Avant que tu que tu donnes ton conseil
pour les jeunes générations, j'ai une
dernière question qui vient de tomber.
Que pens-t-il du 3e mandat anti
constitutionnel d'Alassan Watara
après le coup d'état constitutionnel de
2020 dans son propre pays ? J'espère
qu'il nous donnera une réponse sans
embage.
Non, moi j'ai été contre le 3e mandat.
J'ai été contre le 3e mandat.
D'ailleurs, j'ai sorti un single qui
s'appelle 3e dose qui dénonçait euh le
3e mandat. Et effectivement, je me suis
levé contre le 3e mandat de de d'Alpha
Condé en Guinée en Côte d'Ivoire. Euh
j'ai pas été forcément dans le combat
parce que euh je me suis dit c'est un
pays qui sort d'une grosse crise, 3000
morts après la crise post-électorale. La
paix est très fragile et donc voilà,
j'ai dénoncé le 3è mandat. C'est vrai
que les gens, ils s'attendaient à ce que
je vienne insulter Alassan Attara ou
bien que je vienne m'attaquer
frontalement à San Watara. Euh je l'ai
pas fait. Euh voilà, il y en a qui ont
dit "C'est parce que c'est mon parent,
parce que il vient de sa mère vient du
même village que moi."
Tu connaissais son oncle ?
Euh que voilà que c'est je suis son
oncle et cetera. Mais la raison c'était
que euh c'est un pays très fragile.
C'est un pays qui sortait qui sort d'une
crise. Euh je me suis dit le feu peut
s'allumer plus facilement que que dans
les autres pays. Et c'est pourquoi j'ai
pas été euh frontalement au combat mais
j'ai essayé d'anticiper. J'ai anticipé
euh à travers en chantant une chanson
qui s'appelle la 3è dose. J'ai parlé
dans des interviews mais je pense que
tout le monde s'attendait que j'attaque
Alassan Attara frontalement et ce que
j'ai pas fait et on m'accuse pour ça.
Mais je la raison que je je donne en
tout cas et qui vient de mon cœur, c'est
que c'est un pays très fragile qui sort
de d'une rébellion euh
d'une guerre presque civile hein
puisqueaprès la la crise postitoriale,
la Côte d'Ivoire était à feu et à 100,
il y a eu 3000 morts. Et donc voilà, je
voulais pas attiser le feu, contribuer à
attiser le feu pour que le pays retombe.
Et donc voilà, je suis j'ai été contre
le 3e mandat et je pense que je peux le
dire ouvertement, je suis contre un 4e
mandat d'Asassan Atara que je pense que
lui-même il gagnerait à ne pas faire un
4e mandat. Je pense que pour
tous les grands hommes se sont arrangés.
pour que les grandes œuvres euh voilà
soient entretenu
et voilà, je pense que je souhaite
qu'Alassan Watra fasse la même chose que
après avoir euh sorti de la Côte
d'Ivoire, enfin la Côte d'Ivoire de
zéro aujourd'hui à à un niveau après une
grande coupe d'Afrique que la Côte
d'Ivoire gagne ou qu'elle ne gagne pas,
mais je pense que euh la raison voudrait
que Alassan Ottara laisse la place et
que les Ivoiriens le regrettent si euh
si si s'il a poser des actes positifs,
vaut mieux être regretté que chasser.
Voilà, il vaut mieux être regretter que
chasser.
Je vais demander, tu gardes ton conseil
pour les jeunes générations en tête. Je
te demande je demande à mon équipe
technique d'installer ton guitariste. On
reste en direct.
Ouais. Ouais. On reste en direct. On
coupe rien du tout.
On coupe rien du tout.
J'ai j'ai mes techniciens. On va faire
la causette toi et moi pendant qu'il
travaille.
Ah ouais. Donc là, on va installer ton
guitariste,
tu vas nous chanter deux titres et après
tes deux titres, tu mets le conseil pour
les jeunes générations.
Ouais.
On se Je suis vraiment content que tu
sois venu aujourd'hui. On les laisse On
les laisse bosser.
J'en profite J'en profite pour avoir un
petit moment un peu privilégié.
Quand je t'ai croisé il y a 15 ans à à
Mamutzu
tu m'as donné beaucoup de force. Merci.
Et ta musique ta musique m'a énormément
aidé pour
faire tout ce que j'ai fait avec la
chaîne YouTube. Merci.
Et
un jour, tu m'as dit "On se reverra et
aujourd'hui c'est moi qui te reçois."
Exactement. Ça fait plaisir.
Franchement, Ticken, merci.
Est-ce que Est-ce que mes techniciens
sont prêts ? Est-ce que tout le monde
est prêt ?
Qui c'est qui me donne le top ? Qui
c'est qui leur donne le top ? Parce que
moi non, j'ai plus rien à faire.
Yes ! C'est c'est notre ingénieur du son
patron et le conseil pour les jeunes
générations, ça viendra après.
Est-ce que l'ingénieur du
Donc on va vous on va on va chanter le
premier titre qui est Duro et deè ce
sera euh plus rien ne m'étonne. Voilà.
Ouais, on est parti.
[Musique]
polic
polche
[Musique]
policama
recherche
[Musique]
On va voir.
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Merci
le deè
m'étonne. Voilà.
[Musique]
Ils ont partagé le monde.
Plus rien ne m'étonne.
Rien ne m'étonne.
Rien.
Si tu me laisses la Tchenie,
moi je te laisse l'Arménie.
Si tu me laisses l'Afghanistan,
moi je te laisse le Pakistan.
Si tu ne quittes pas Haïti,
moi je t'embangi.
Si tu mets dans bomba de l'Irak, moi je
t'arrange le Kurdistan.
Ils ont partagé le monde.
BR
ils ont partagé le monde. Aïe aïe aïe.
Br ne m'étonne.
Rien ne m'étonne.
Si tu me laisses l'uranium,
moi je te laisse l'aluminium.
Si tu me laisses tes gésems,
moi je t'aide à chasser les talibans. Si
tu me donnes beaucoup de blé, moi je
fais la guerre à tes côtés.
Si tu me laisses extrait ton enor moi
j'étais dans mettre le général dehors.
Ils ont partagé le monde.
Rien ne m'étonne
plus rien ne m'étonne.
Rien ne m'étonne.
Ils ont partagé le monde. Aïe aïe aïe.
Plus rien ne m'étonne.
Rien ne m'étonne.
Mant
[Musique]
ils ont partagé Africa
sans nous consulter
et
que nous soyons désunis. Une partie de
l'empire mandain
se trouva chez le Walaf.
Une partie de l'empire mossi se trouva
dans le Ghana.
Une partie de l'empire soussou se trouva
dans l'empire Mandin. Une partie de
l'empire Mandin se trouva chez les mos
aussi.
Ils ont partagé mama
[Musique]
Africa,
ils ont partagé le monde.
Primant
plus prenant
plus mant
ils ont partagé le monde. Aïe aïe aïe.
[Musique]
plus
ils ont partagé le monde.
Plus mét
plus ne
plus ne m
[Musique]
Merci beaucoup. Merci.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Ben les jeunes
générations, je voudrais leur dire
simplement de voilà de prendre le
travail au sérieux, quel que soit le
domaine dans lequel ils sont, parce que
voilà, le travail ne tue pas mais ça
paye et donc voilà et pour parler des
artistes la nouvelle génération, je
pense que euh si on est là aujourd'hui,
nous on est là aujourd'hui. Il suffit
qu'il regarde dans notre passé comment
on a commencé pour comprendre que nous
étions des acharnés au travail.
et que voilà et que c'est c'est le
résultat de cet acharnement au travail
qui qui fait qu'on est là aujourd'hui.
Et donc voilà, quel que soit le domaine
dans lequel vous êtes, il faut prendre
le travail au sérieux, il faut penser au
résultat du travail parce qu'il y en a
qui mettent l'argent devant. Voilà, on
guettete l'argent qu'on va gagner mais
on ne tient pas compte de la
satisfaction de celui qui va nous donner
de l'argent. Et je pense que voilà,
c'est ce qui fait la différence.
entre la génération d'aujourd'hui et la
génération d'hier. Et je souhaite que
euh la génération d'aujourd'hui se
comporte comme la génération d'hier sur
tous les plans presque et donc voilà,
c'est le conseil que je peux donner à la
nouvelle génération.
Tick Jaacoli, merci.
C'est moi, c'est moi qui vous remercie.
[Musique]